e
e e
thank
you I open the public hearing on
children and family law committee for
Tuesday February 4th
2025 and a couple of business items
first Prime sponsor of House Bill 553
representative Greg request subcommittee
to do some work on it in the hopes we
can execute fairly soon and the chair
appoints representative Greg to chair
this that means uh when you schedule
you've got to go to the committee
assistant Special K and let her know and
that means it's by Wednesday noon I also
appoint Gabby
Grossman learning the name it's been
three
years Deb D Simone Kim rice and Jody
Nelson to this sub
committee we
also
got we also uh welcome to um
Replacements and if The Replacements
would introduce themselves
I'm uh representative Buzz Sher I'm
normally on House of Criminal Justice
I'm from uh Rockingham 26 pouth ward 3
so if you hear a slight Buzz over in
this end of the room he's a buzz but
he's not slight and also I apologize for
the
chair and I'm Janet Lucas I'm from
Grafton district 7 which is Campton and
I'm usually on Health and Human Services
El Affairs my old committee yes right
all right and I got some more
announcements that I will be making
later I open the hearing now on House
Bill 486 relative to grandparents
visitation rights and the chair
recognizes
you representative Nelson with the
clerk's duties now being assumed by our
Deputy
clerk uh
486 we have
and just a reminder and continuing
education if somebody
speaks from the witness table on a bill
that means when they return to their
seat if they're on this committee they
are not uh allowed to ask questions of
uh others who testify but there is a
workaround which I explained the other
day and that is when I was on Health and
Human Services I was sitting next to Dr
Jerry
kerk and he introduced the bill and he
was just sitting there dying to ask
questions so he handed me a note saying
ask this
question and all would have gone
smoothly but I did say Dr kerk and of
course a sentence in his handwriting
degenerated and I looked to him and said
Jerry what's that word and that kind of
gave it all away but generally speaking
that's the rule
here so please introduce your bill to us
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
members of the committee I'm here to
testify
on uh House Bill 486 and I am the prime
sponsor a constituent brought her issue
with real trouble she was having being
granted grandparents
visitation uh to me and asked me to look
at RSA
461a colon 13 as I started to Res search
and speak with other grandparents and
people from organizations who help
grandparents I realized that there were
some changes to current law that really
needed to be made I tread very lightly
because of my respect for parents rights
and didn't want to encroach on those
rights when I was trying to think of
language that would help grandparents I
was relieved and very thankful that two
very active and influential parents
rights supporters signed in in support
of the bill so I believe I have
successfully accomplished that um what
did I do I added separate living
arrangements to circumstances to
supplement the circumstance of divorce
as we know divorces can take years and
it's not in the best interest of the
child to wait years to continue a
positive relationship with their
grandparents this could interfere with
the frequency of contact consideration
also depending on the interpretation of
divorce in this instance is it fair to
determine that grandparents should be
disqualified because they haven't seen
their grandchildren during the course of
long divorce proceedings how do judge
judges determine what the definition of
divorce is in this case is it after the
final decree is it during the course of
the divorce it seems like there really
isn't one answer and it's open to a lot
of
interpretation we've also seen a lot of
grandparents in New Hampshire raising
grandchild children as we know we see
them a lot here um in our committee and
I've seen estimates up to 12,000
grandparents currently who are raising
grandchildren in their homes and as we
know unfortunately a large contributing
factor to this huge population of
grandparents raising grandkids is due to
per parental drug abuse many
grandparents have temporary guardianship
for several months six or more at a time
and while the goal is often
reunification and we hope reunification
with the parent or parents is permanent
and successful the reality is that
recovery can be a bumpy road
grandparents can be going back and forth
from parents to grandparents as their
parents are battling their addictions
maintaining a positive relationship with
grandparents is crucial to the
well-being of the child in situations
like this this is why I've added the
language in lines 15 16 and 17 this
language is in current legislation in
other states and it seems to be working
I found an AR and a help guide for
grandparents entitled help for
grandparents and Kinship Caregivers
impacted by opioids or other substance
use disorders about understanding
attachment and bonding long title sorry
I just wanted to read you a portion of
that article it does a great job
explaining why this is important and to
justify adding the lines I'm talking
about young children need to develop at
least one relationship with one primary
caregiver for healthy social and
emotional development to occur children
become attached to the adults who are
sensitive and responsive to them and
remain constant early in their life this
person is their secure base children who
experienced a parents substance use
disorder may have felt abandonment due
to their parents absence or lack of
attentiveness to their needs and
children who have been removed from
their birth parent and go to live with
their grandparent or k kin caregiver
develop an attachment to them the total
loss of that attachment person can cause
anxiety and grief in the child that's
why it's critically important that the
unification planning for the child must
include mechanisms to continue at least
one relationship with one the bond with
the grandparents or kidship Giver while
at the same time strengthening the
parental bond this shouldn't be a them
versus US type of
situation that's about it and I hope
I've communicated the need for these
changes enough for you to support the
bill and I would be happy to take
questions any questions representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for presenting this bill and um for
taking my question what how did you come
on the time frame of uh the six months
thank you for the question I researched
uh all of the law all the grandparent
visitation laws and that's in Statute in
other states including Arkansas exactly
how it's written and I had not found uh
there be any problem with that in those
States and that's where I got that exact
language representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so I'm
curious about um the stipulation that
the child has to have lived with the
grandparent for the grandparent to have
um visitation rights does does the
language change make that requirement or
can it still be a situation like I'm
thinking about a friend of mine who who
goes to her daughter's house every day
gets the children ready for school takes
them to school and then watches them
after school should something happen she
would probably want to continue to have
a relationship with those kids would
that still be something that a judge
could
order or does because she doesn't
actually physically live with them does
the language change change that thank
you for your question um it doesn't
change um at all um it's just in
addition to what we have currently in in
statute thank
you ping no other hands up thank you so
much back and the chair recognizes Mr
Frank
kland he says he's got testimony that
came to us online
that we have two
seats can you share a microphone in a
nice
way than you've worked that one out yeah
my wife and I say the third first 37
years are the hardest
but I'll allow it it's okay and the
hardest part of testing ifying is making
sure your microphone is
on and you know it is when there's a red
light looking at
you you got to push the button
though Bingo good morning chair and
members I'm testifying today to in
support of the uh grandparents
visitation
law grandparents have always been and
continue to be an integral part of the
family for Millennia of generations they
are the keepers of wisdom care and
tradition that binds the legacy of the
collective family grandparents are the
peacekeepers the confidants and the
protectors a safe haven in the storm
parents who exploit this trust with
self-absorbing agendas to the point of
attacking the very people who supported
and cared for them in their childhood
are ultimately damaging their own
children without morality by denying any
contact with grandparents those parents
who Gaslight their own offspring to
again attack the only Safe Haven have
lost their way grandparents need to
continue to be part of the grandkids
lives and vice versa without question I
asked this Committee of lawmakers to
take the high road and pass this
legislation unencumbered this is in the
best interest of the kids first last and
always any questions any
questions I just want to look at their
picture for another 30
seconds that's so good I'm G to guess
you're a grandfather
I'm a proxy got her I'm the grandmother
he was their adopted Papa
okay any questions well seeing none
thank you so much appreciate you
coming we'll allow you to take the
photos back okay
yeah chair recognizes uh de Deborah
conar is it do I have it right
oh oh okay counts as one thank you chair
recognizes Stacy DBA
Mimi to
roian sorry
no good morning Mr
chair and committee
members my name is Stacy ter Roan I'm
here as a very very concerned
grandmother but I do support this bill
with some recommended
changes my granddaughters have been
alienated and isolated from
me not just me but my entire family that
has loved and supported them for the
last two years we have not seen them or
had any contact with
them after 18 months of
litigation my case was dismissed due to
the language in section one of this
current
RSA this language weaponizes bad parents
against good- loving grandparents like
myself who seek visitations with good
cause and concern for the safety and the
well-being of their
grandchildren particularly in situations
where there is a genuine risk of abuse
and neglect in the house most
grandparents seek visitations as a way
of providing a Lifeline to the
grandchildren in case of adverse
circumstances and the children needing
to be reunited with their
grandparents will judge gooper
he granted me visitations no names no
names pleas I'm sorry at two separate
hearings in which my daughter would not
comply and August 2024 we were scheduled
for a contempt hearing for
non-compliance of his visitation orders
and as I walked into the courtroom I was
ambushed with a new judge who i' had
never seen before and who I believe was
not familiar with our case history and
my daughter's attorney presented me with
a motion to dismiss that I had never
seen till that moment I was not given 10
days notice or any time to appeal my
contempt hearing now became into a
hearing to dismiss my case after 18
months of
litigation he was the other judge was no
longer hearing our case the other judge
knew the extenuating circumstances of
this case including the history of child
endangerment neglect drug and alcohol
abuse assault and battery domestic
violence and mental health issues along
with two incarcerations in which I was
the primary caretaker of my
grandchildren and many dcyf
Assessments in
2019 when my daughter separated from her
husband my daughter and my
granddaughters came to live with me for
a year and a
half and during that time my daughter
became incarcerated for child
endangerment and I became the primary
caretaker of my two youngest
granddaughters who were only 1 and 2
years old at this time my daughter lost
custody of her eldest daughter to her
father but she would come and spend
almost every weekend with me and her
sisters my daughter to this day still
does not have custody to her eldest
daughter who's 12 years old
now after my daughter was released from
prison she moved into an apartment
upstairs from me with my two youngest
granddaughters so I would be close by to
help with the girls and be a constant
support for her well two years ago my
daughter suffered a second overdose on
heroin laced with fenol while my three
grandchildren were present in the home
sleeping and as a result DCF placed the
girls in my
custody after providing nine months of
care during which the girls showed
remarkable improvements in their health
they were happy they were thriving and I
supported the reunification of my
daughter with her children
again immediately following this
reunification my daughter who was still
separated from her husband now restricts
all contact between myself and my
granddaughters
this judge based on his interpretation
of section one of the RSA stated because
I was restricted prior to the absence of
the nuclear family as in section one of
this RSA that I had no standing no
grounds for grandparent
visitations and he had no power to Grant
or enforce any visitations or writes to
me as a grandmother and he dismissed my
case and again that was his
interpretation after 18 months of
litigation even though I had two granted
visitations at two separate hearings
with the last being a final order with a
visitation
schedule my daughter refused to
comply and was held in contempt but
there was never any consequences there
was no penalties no repercussions for
non-compliant and being in
contempt because my daughter was
separated not divorced at the time that
she restricted me upon
reunification I have no recourse to ever
see my grandchildren again who I loved
and I nurtured their entire young
lives she is now divorced but I still
have no rights to petition the court for
visitations how is that fair to the
children who love their grandmother this
not only hurts me but it hurts my girls
emotionally being ripped away from me
they loving
Mimi they spent so many years with me
and I miss my grand God is daily
sorry the isolation and alienation it's
not fair to them it's not feir to me
it's not fair to my
family for the last 12 years I was
called Mimi and I no longer hear those
voices anymore nobody calls me Mimi any
go
more and I'm grieving the loss of living
grandchildren that are just in the next
city over from
me in August
2024 7 months after reunification with
their mother I became aware that my
youngest 5-year-old granddaughter was
severely burned using the microwave
preparing her own mail while my daughter
was in
bed this caused me great concern and
worry for my granddaughter's safety and
well-being I strongly support this bill
with recommended changes so that all
grandparents have the right to
visitations and relationships with their
grandchildren
and I urges committee to do the right
thing and pass this
bill other grandparents are suffering
like
myself and we just want to be a Lifeline
to our
grandchildren and in and unfortunately
when your child is involved with drugs
and alcohol they don't want the children
to be involved with the grandparents
because they're in fear they're in fear
the children will unknowingly say
something to the grandparent that could
get the into some trouble so it's fear
to isolate everybody so nobody has
access to what's going on in that home
and one of the pictures I showed you
that I passed out I went to go that was
a visitation I was supposed to go get my
granddaughters they didn't come out but
all the windows were boarded up with
cardboard boxes and sheets so my poor
grandchildren can't even see outside in
the
daylight they can't see outside and I
couldn't see in and two years she's had
time to brainwash them all against me
beloving grandmother I sacrificed so
many so many years and so much of my
time in energy on these beautiful little
girls to be ripped away from
me will you take questions from us yes
absolutely um you suggest some changes
to the bill we will vote on this bill at
some point and we could possibly make
changes do you have the suggested
changes WR out for us I don't at this
time but it was that current line that I
was restricted prior to the absence of
the nuclear family because she
restricted me while she was separated
okay for any reason and he said the
court has no power to grant me
visitations what you just said would be
very helpful if you wrote that out for
us okay uh absent that we grant you that
changes could be made but we will not
know how to make those Chang
we will vote the bill as we have it but
if you have specifics please get them to
us as soon as you can and then when we
go to discuss it in committee um it is
possible that an amendment could be
crafted thank you thank you uh
representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman that was
my question about the specific language
changes so
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here and
thank you for taking my question and
sharing your very painful story um I
just wondered because I want to wrap my
head around the the legal side of this
did you appeal that decision because
with the first judge coming in then the
second was there any kind of app pellet
situation with that the first judge
granted I had two hearings temporary and
final at both hearings he granted me
visitations so I wasn't expecting it to
be a contempt here and we was I mean I
wasn't expecting it to be a a hearing to
dismiss my case it was supposed to be
for contempt and the case got
dismissed so no I did not appeal it
because I you didn't appeal the second
decision I didn't because the way he
said it in the law the law interprets it
he interpreted it that I have no rights
he had no power to grant me visitation
because the way the law was written I
was restricted prior to the absence of
the nuclear family and even though they
he had moved on in another relationship
and wasn't living in the house he
considered them a nuclear family
sure were you represented by council at
this hearing I was proos okay but the
opposite was of councel yes with councel
yes okay thank you representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you so much I just want to say that I am
a papa to three uh grandchildren who I
love dearly yes and I cannot imagine
being alienated from them so I hear your
testimony and I feel your pain and I
just want to thank you very much for
being here welcome you're
welcome any other
questions and I had one other thing to
say we have over 170
supporters for this bill online and a
lot of testimonies I lobbied this bill
because it's so important to me and de
in my heart and it means so much to me
to get this bill passed for not just me
but all the grandparents that are
suffering like me and the grandchildren
that are suffering wondering where their
loving grandmother or grandfather went
there is one testimony I was would like
you to read and his name is uh Hubert
novel his testimony relates to my exact
story he has gone through the exact same
thing as I have if you could read that
one specific testimony it might bring a
little more insight into the language in
this in this law that needs to be
amended thank you thank you thank you
for coming thank
you and we will look forward to that um
document from you so we can consider
amending it uh I have a card for a
Deborah
conar do I have it right no do I have do
I have Deborah right no one ever does
all right but Deborah is correct Deborah
is correct and your last name is it is
SM it is what smar just pretend it's an
s c m a
r got
it thank you thank you thank you for uh
being here today and considering the
amendment to this bill um my husband and
I have three granddaughters ages 11 8
and five our son and daughter-in-law and
their growing family lived in our home
with us for almost 3 and a half years
while they saved up and eventually built
their house in Chai Chester we are in
constant contact with them seeing them
weekly and or and FaceTime timing or
messaging several times during the week
we always attend and support their
extracurricular activities have them
over for sleepovers often when their
mother requests it to give her a break
we've rented houses on the cape and
lakewi a so our families can be
together for
vacations last August after a long time
coming everything fell apart in their
marriage our son was arrested he has PTS
and substance problems and a restraining
order was issued against him he has not
been able to see his children since that
time but he would like us to be able to
see them we have continued to support
our daughter-in-law and grandchildren
emotionally spending any time we can
with them in early November we had all
three gr girls over for as sleepover and
everything was great we were supposed to
have them for our family Thanksgiving
that morning our daughter-in-law texted
and informed us that the girls were not
comfortable with us and that she would
not force them to see us she ignored our
request to have them for Christmas which
we previously told were told would be
fine we have gone to our granddaughter's
basketball games and the girls will now
not look at us or speak to
us our granddaughters are being
alienated from us and from our entire
family we have a very close-nit loving
family we have never said a word to them
against their mother and have only have
their best interest at heart we are
trying to obtain visitation with them to
repair the damage that has been done to
our
relationship however as the law is
written now we have little hope of that
happening until their divorce is
finalized which could take a couple of
years as it's very
contentious outside of their parents my
husband and I have been the most
consistent and supportive presence in
our grandchildren's lives we're the only
ones who were ever allowed to Babys H
them or spend time with them her family
was not even involved in
that we ask that you and that you enact
House Bill 486 to amend the criteria
for grandparent visitation so that we
can work at repairing that relationship
thank you thank you and any questions
for the
witness seeing none thank you so much
thank you I have no more pink cards on
this so I
will conclude our hearing on House Bill
486 and we will uh put this one aside
for a week or two awaiting any further
information before we go to vote on
it with that I open the hearing on House
Bill 320 an act relative to enforcement
of marital property settlements and
representative marel from our committee
is the prime sponsor
and at some point you owe me a pink card
um okay I'm sorry Mr chairman your
credit is good okay thank you I'll get
that in and
um thank you for allowing me to speak
beh I'm sorry thank you for allowing me
to speak on behalf of this bill um what
320 does is basically a couple of things
first um it plugs a hole in the current
law two things I'm passing around one is
um a copy of RSA
4816a which is the statutory factors
that a court that courts consider when
it makes property settlements and and um
what is missing is
basically House Bill 320 and I'll
explain why there is
no there is no statutory requirement
that any Court enforce any of its orders
that it makes once a decree has become
final now there's a would you say that
again because that is wow please yeah it
is wow and it's very unfortunate there
to my knowledge there is no statutory
requirement that a court enforce a final
decree when it becomes
final um I haven't seen it and I the on
the basis for this bill was a profoundly
disturbing experience that I have had in
a court in this in this state uh where a
court simply refused to enforce its
decree resulting in basically a um
resulting in um a uh a significant
deprivation of property and
unfortunately the Corum does not allow
me to go into the specifics of the case
publicly um I can tell you that the I
can tell you that the decision to
enforce the decree uh was in part based
on activity which rose in which in black
and white terms Rose to the level of
perjury and was provable I can also tell
you it involved intentional conversion
of assets uh and the court when
presented with this evidence simply
declined to enforce its decree now
there's a difference between enforcement
and contempt and it's important that you
know the difference between the two
contempt is basically a vile is in in
New Hampshire it's basically a willful
or intentional violation of a court
order okay enforcement doesn't
necessarily involve
contempt uh contempt historically is
discretionary upon a court
uh so a court can find you in contempt
or not find you in contempt uh depending
on the circumstances and it's largely
discretionary and that's historical
since contempts have been in existence
when you look at HB when you look at 320
the elements that a court can consider
in whether or not to um whether or not
to enforce a decree are basically well
settled so I'm going to ask I'm
respectfully direct the committee's
attention to uh paragraph 7 uh line S
I'm sorry where in other words once a
decree becomes final uh that means no
more appeals are allowed or an appeal is
taken place or post trial or
postdecision motions have been resolved
there is basically nothing else to go on
in terms of further activity and that's
basically finality of judgment so when
you look at what would be invalid would
be whether a decree was either entered
into either by agreement of the parties
or by after a final hearing by a court
would be fraud deceit duress
impossibility okay misrepresentation
Mutual mistake undue influence or
subsequent illegality and that would be
shown by a preponderance of the evidence
now fraud duress deceit
misrepresentation Mutual mistake and
undo influence are well settled are well
settled reasons uh to set aside a
property decree in the state of New
Hampshire uh you can go back case law
all the way back and you'll see that uh
basically if you want to look it up one
key case on that is De palatino from
1995 which recites in its case you know
historic precedent for setting aside a
decree based on that um I chose to add
some contract information because that
can become a contract so when you look
at the word impossibility in other words
if somehow it was entered into and
subsequent enforcement became impossible
okay or subsequent illegality those
might be reasons to not enforce a decree
to its terms uh an example of that for
example might be let's say
hypothetically uh one of the agre one of
the agreed upon things was to um
transfer 10 cases of an imported Russian
vodka to be delivered two years down the
road and the thing becomes final well
all of a sudden the United States
decides to ban the importation of
Russian vodka and all of a sudden
compliance is impossible okay or also
illegal if it becomes a criminal
activity to import Russian vodka so
those might be two defenses the rest of
it is when you look at it is basically
contract law okay which is a big part of
what goes on in agreements and decrees
which is the court shell fashion
remedies that place the parties in the
position as if the decree had been fully
performed according to its terms now uh
then this is important um and the reason
why is because if for some reason there
needs to be an adjustment courts can
fashion remedies that will put the
parties basically in the same position
um and can be done now the worst part of
this is is that you really do not have a
viable appeal going up to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court if a court if a
court below simply declines to enforce
an order and that is
frightening um the other aspect of why
this thing is written the way it is is
because I think as we have seen on this
committee people need to learn how to
plead their cases Approximately 80%
of the people who go into court at least
in the family division one side of that
case is probably a self-represented
individual so in other words with this
clear and unambiguous language people
learn how to plead their cases
effectively so they know okay well
what's happened in this case why am I
here to enforce why am I here seeking a
contempt and what would the possible
defenses that a court could accept would
be so you can argue your case
effectively and please it effectively
and that teaches and that basically
improves the administration of law the
second aspect of it is is that courts
need to be on notice that their ability
to be able to enforce a decree okay is
is there uh so a court can simply look
at this and realize that it has to
Fashion remedies and uh that basically
put the parties in the position that
they were in if um
uh as if the as if the decree had been
fully performed and the nice part about
this language is is that it allows
parties whether this is a decree by
agreement or whether it is the result of
a the result of a contested matter that
they can argue the case effectively um
and so without this
statute I am afraid that since this has
happened at least once and in this
particular court uh that I can refer to
it's probably happened to other people
and so I don't I know I'm speaking for
at least one party and I think I'm
probably speaking for a lot of other
people who may have faced this problem
but have not been able to figure out how
to deal with it and uh without this
statute this kind of behavior can
continue you know one of the things that
in more controversial subjects
there's one way that courts look at it
and it's called Uh this is capable of
repetition yet evading review and uh
that's an often repeated thing in Prior
US Supreme Court cases and this is
clearly capable of repetition and
evading review I'll be happy to take any
questions anyone has I'll start with a
couple as I'm prepping for
elets
okay the uh vodka example you used of
impossibility is that Force majour um no
actually it's not for well it could be
considered for yeah it could be
considered Force majure but you either
have either you have subsequent
illegality of subject matter or
impossibility so it could be if the
importation was banned it might be
impossible to do it however if it also
became criminalized to possess Russian
vodka then it would be illegality of
subject matter and forc maure is not
second question when you say the uh you
prefer the word enforcement to contempt
because if I'm not mistaken is
contempt uh one has to prove intent and
that is very difficult to imp to prove
but enforcement is more discretionary
and it's on preponderance of evidence do
I have that correct um they are flip
sides of the same coin okay so for
example in New Hampshire there are are
lots of different definitions of
contempt but concisely put the consensus
in New Hampshire is contempt is usually
basically a willful act uh it's usually
an intentional refusal to comply with a
court order or a uh usually it's a
refusal to comply with a court order
okay and there's usually a willfulness
component to it uh previously we talked
about uh outlining the the elements of
contempt in New Hampshire in this
committee and uh the definition should
be broadened but it's going to be
discretionary on the judge and I have
seen judges import case law okay from
other jurisdictions in finding somebody
to be a contempt
okay that's true that's how much
discretion is in it um and this needs to
be done for predictability I'm sorry if
I'm talking beyond your point um all
right having passed the practice elat
for family law I'm working on contracts
next any other
questions yes representative
Grossman thank you chairman Pearson um
and thank you representative for
introducing this to us um so
what I guess in like layman's terms sure
how would this give the judge power now
they would be able to
enforce um if you can describe now what
would happen Okay so for example right
now a judge can simply pick up a
potential contempt or or similarly a
motion to enforce and bear in mind
enforcement doesn't necessarily have to
have the willfulness of a contempt and
that's the difference I want to clarify
okay um in some jurisdictions I'll muddy
the waters just a little in some
jurisdictions okay a negligent failure
to comply with an order is contemptuous
conduct okay but in New Hampshire we
favor the willfulness okay or the
enforcement can be whatever okay just
never got around to it so you're not
looking for a contempt you're looking to
enforce
um so this would tell a judge okay this
is the elements now whatever is going on
here with the conditions precedent not
being in the way no duress No undo
influence uh no particular change of uh
circumstances blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah okay then the judge is going
to have to look and say okay how do I
enforce a remedy okay how do I even
create a remedy which is what basically
Equitable jurisdiction is all about that
puts the party in their positions as
they should be informed now let's carry
that this way for example let's assume
for the sake of discussion here that
somebody is awarded stock rights in the
context of the divorce and let's assume
that there is um and let's assume for
example that the stock rights are being
cashed in by the other party let's
further assume that that party Cashes in
the stock rights and due to subject due
to withholding on this on the stock
units says okay I'm giving you half of
what you're entitled
to and you say well I'm entitled to the
full amount that the court ordered me
and he says no it's withheld and but in
the meanwhile there is a remedy to be
done because what you can do if you're
in that situation is you can fill out
the appropriate tax forms okay which let
you deduct from your income the value of
the money that you
took okay now if you bring this to a
Court's attention why would a court
refuse to enforce it and actually pay
the party the money that they're owed
Court says not going to do
it you're out it's not
reviewable okay other
questions yes representative
sure thank you uh Mr chair and I wish
you luck on the
elets we rehearse this in um so I'm
trying I assume you're talking there's
two kinds of contempt in New Hampshire
criminal contempt and civil contempt
correct and you're talking about civil
contempt correct and in many
jurisdictions and I've only dealt with
criminal contempt not personally
but um in many jurisdictions with civil
contempt the court has the power to
either incarcerate someone for failure
until they cure the contempt correct um
or to find them for each day each week
each month they don't cure the contempt
is that the case in New Hampshire uh yes
uh basically we do have civil contempt
and criminal contempt occasionally the
lines blur uh but generally speaking in
a civil contempt the contner holds the
key to the uh jailhouse door okay which
means that is when you purge yourself of
contempt uh by performing an act or
doing whatever you're supposed to do
we're going to let you out of jail and
that's assuming the contempt is so
egregious that the Court's going to put
the case on for a show cause hearing in
New Hampshire which is typically what
happens as part of due process before
they decide to make an incarceration
decision criminal contempt for example
would be more like what happened to
Steve Bannon okay where he simply
refused to comply with the subpoena and
show up okay okay there's other examples
of criminal contempt which I did an
article on this for the New Hampshire
bar news um last year uh which predicate
it which preceded that bill and I'm
happy to provide it with you to give you
the definition if you need it followup
follow followup so in terms of enforcing
the uh the final property settlement why
isn't it effective for the judge to say
for every week you don't perform that
which you're required to do on the
property settlement I'm going to find
you $1,000 or $5,000 you know set an
amount like that isn't that a pretty
effective enforcement mechanism as it
currently exists it would be but it's
entirely discretionary on the court on
the part of a judge because remember the
power for contempt is entirely
discretionary what this does is that
this makes an important distinction you
don't have to be found in contempt under
this statute a proposed statute if
becomes law all you need to do is be
able to look to enforce a decree so you
can plead a contempt and the court can
find one of two things it can find that
a you are in contempt in the altern and
enforce it or the court can find there
was no willfulness here or it didn't
meet the elements that the court would
find relevant for contempt and simply
enforce the
decree and last followup yeah followup
um so really this comes down to at least
in the contempt context uh comes down to
um
well let me take that back and rephrase
the question why not just have why not
just take contempt out of it and just
have uh uh upon motion or petition by a
party for enforcement why do we need to
even have the words cont because they
are two because they are flip sides of
the same coin and so a court can either
find you in contempt the court has the
op so it gives two ways to plead a case
number one is is that if you don't think
it's in contempt the person pleading the
plaint if or the petitioner in this case
can if doesn't think it's in doesn't
think it's a contempt or doesn't think
the Court's going to find them in
contempt they can plead to inforce okay
and the court has the and so that's why
it because there are two different
causes of action within the law you can
seek to enforce your decree which isn't
necessarily contempt or you can actually
file a contempt and say that this is not
only enforceable but it is also
contemptuous conduct on the part of the
defendant or respondent thank thank
you any other
questions thank you thank you and thank
you I thank the
committee and by the way if you look in
your handout you'll see the statute
where it fits and you'll also see what a
petition for contempt looks like okay
and
unfortunately it is what it is thank you
um we're going to have a five minute
recess in which case Republicans stay in
the room and Democrats follow the
ranking member and this is for the
purpose of are we ready to exec this
bill
so I have no further cards no
there are four doors exiting this room
and you may use any one of them but use
one of them go
go
e
e e
I did not close the hearing I recessed
it so we are back do you wish your
questions to be internal to the
committee or to the prime sponsor which
is effectively the same
thing would you wish to ask for the
questions of the Prime sponsor or would
you like to ponder the questions and
come back at another time when he will
be here Choice two okay so we're ready
now then to close the hearing okay I
close the hearing on whatever this is
House Bill
320 now we've got an exact possibility
here that uh the ranking member and I
have discussed
let me get my paperwork together
here how can I lose things so quickly
I open an executive session on House
Bill
213 uh an act relative to wage
garnishment for child support and the
question was raised to me from the
ranking member about a fiscal note is
that correct that is correct
and um I have made two copies of this so
when I'm done reading one copy I'll let
you take a look at
it uh we asked I asked the uh budget
office legislative budget
assistant for where is the fiscal note
and this is an email to her from her
Melissa
Rollins to me yesterday at 2:23 p.m.
following up on your phone call HB 213
has been determined to have no fiscal
impact based on responses from the
judicial branch and
DHHS
DHHS indicated that any Associated costs
could be absorbed within their existing
budget so does that take care of the
question so are we ready to go good I
love it when a plan comes
together one second here oh
crap
um wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait here we go
chair recognizes representative sidel
for a motion thank you Mr chair I'd like
to move um HB 213 to OTP please the
motion is ought to pass
a wonderful colleague from across the
aisle to Second
it representative Greg is that wonderful
colleague from across the aisle the
motion before us is on House Bill
213 which is an act relative to wage
garnishment for child's support it was
moved by representative sidal and
seconded by representative
Greg when the clerk is ready please call
the
rooll chairman Pearson
yes Vice chair representative D Simone
yes representative
rice yes representative McMahon
representative Nelson like yes
representative s
yes representative love representative
coren yes representative Marquel yes
representative patrino yes that's speak
representative
Gman yes representative
lest
oh
yes representative Greg oh
yes representative Raymond
the part of Representative George repres
is
Lucas yes thank you representative
Malone
yes representative MCM
no just
presid 15 16
the bill passes 16 to
Z it passed 16 to Zer
unanimous
yeses yeah so it's
15 okay he was not present at the time
the thing was called so 15 to
zero I would you like it on
consent any objections to it being on
consent going on consent going on
consent and representative Sidell if you
would be so kind please as to have the
committee
reports ahead of time okay or the blur
of either one
can with this I close the executive
session on House
Bill
213 I also believe ranking memb said it
would be okay I think to go to House
Bill
243 relative to the uh I open then the
exec session on House Bill 243 FN
relative to the penalty for false
reports of suspected abuse and neglect
made to the division for children youth
and
families and the chair recognizes
representative Nelson for a
motion thank thank you Mr chairman I
would like to uh pass this motion of
OTP okay do I have a
second from one of the other folks
second I want to get a Democrat on I
like to do that no you don't want to do
that no no D no D no D no D team they
haven't oh okay uh I saw a hand over
here earlier representative sidel
discussion representative
rice so I cannot support this bill I am
too concerned about harm
coming um to children so I will be
voting no on the UT to pass motion how
would you see harm coming to children
I would see PE
people being afraid to report abuse or
neglect for fear it would be considered
malicious
okay anyone
else representative Petrino thank you Mr
chairman the way I read the uh bill it
seems that individuals who want to make
it anonymous uh call can still do so so
if they have malicious intent well they
can just remain anonymous however uh on
the other end of the phone uh the
individual will hear that potentially
there could be civil or criminal
penalties for any kind of faults and
that may be chilling to some and they
may be hesitant to move forward and that
right there I think would potentially
Put Some Children at Risk and even if uh
we're talking one child uh that's one
child too
many representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman um just as I did last uh
session I have some pretty strong
feelings about this bill and I also
understand the psychology of the people
that are going to think twice about this
the conscientious people that are going
to worry about is this malicious is am I
doing the right things are not the ones
that we would need to worry about anyone
anyway people that have malicious intent
they're going to do this anyway because
they don't care they're already doing
something that's illegal police reports
and stuff that's already illegal to file
a police report um I also want
to caution that we had testimony that
the previous uh DCF um what is it called
chair whatever so which was Joe ripsom
sat in here and said that he was okay
with this he did not he actually sat in
here and said please don't pass this the
last time we had this bill let them
decide and decipher they would rather
get all the calls and not try to
prohibit calls from coming in we're
missing so many already let's let them
do their job that they're trained to do
and decipher these calls without you
know letting the public know that they
could be in trouble because even the
people that are not doing a maliciously
because of a good conscience and people
that have the best intentions they will
they will think that twice they will go
ah I don't know and that will make it
even more so I know because I've had to
I've had to make calls before um I know
that representative uh Vice chair D
Simon has also talked about her having
to make calls we're the ones that second
guess this bills like that make those
people second guess it more thank
you representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um so for me it really comes
down to because I've worked in a state
that has this law um but we have the
office of the child advocate who the
legislature created to review how child
um welfare is happening in New Hampshire
and advise us to the potential impacts
of bills and how we can make things
better for kids and when the office of
the child advocate says that they're in
opposition to a bill I take that very
seriously um because they are our first
you know they are our
um well o I would say OverWatch right
they're the people who are um making
sure that there's oversight and so for
me um if the oversight agent says this
is not a good idea um then I tend to
fall on the this is probably not a good
idea
side representative
sure uh I I had a long conversation with
the uh the office of the child advocate
on a bill that was pending concerning
child neglect in house criminal justice
Public Safety and and this piece of this
that bill didn't relate to this but um
uh we got into the conversation about
this kind of thing and um she was very
persuasive to me that let's
not try and criminalize too much when it
relates to uh child neglect uh let's uh
let the parts of the system that is DCF
handle that kind of issue rather than
criminalizing it and it was pretty
persuasive to
me representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman I'm sensitive to um what people
have been talking about and I thought a
lot about this um I supported it last
time and I've done more research this
time um there are F false reporting
penalties in Most
states and some states have
um laws that include fines and some
states have laws regarding this um that
include prison time we have red States
and blue States alike who have um
laws um that uh penalize individuals who
falsely
report California
Massachusetts Michigan York Texas New
York um and we heard during testimony
that should New Hampshire create a law
uh penalizing false reporting that
people would be less inclined and and
afraid to report actual cases of abuse
which are concerns here in this room too
but there was no data that was provided
to those uh test from those testifying
to support that
statement um and there there was no
findings um that that occurred in other
states so that is why I am in support of
this thank
you since these comments seem to go very
much to the heart of the bill you know
some things you can amend all you want
but that's usually on the edges it seems
to me that all an amendment would do
would be to take this thing away the
choice really seems to me to be up or
down uh anybody
else representative D Simon thank you Mr
chairman with all due respect to
everybody who's spoken on both sides of
this
issue uh I have called and reported and
yes I did think about the ramifications
if I was found to be um just considered
a troublemaker but it did not deter me I
felt strong enough about the fact that a
child could be being
abused uh I was ready to accept any
consequences because I was on calling on
behalf of the
child so
I just feel that since there is no data
to prove that it decreases the amount of
legitimate callers on the issue uh I can
still support the Bill thank
you represent
patrino thank you Mr chairman so U I
know all of our towns have those uh
Facebook pages where residents can kind
of chime in and uh so in Milford uh
we're no different and just recently
somebody had posted and I thought it was
an interesting post it said I heard a
little girl
screaming and I'm not sure what to do
because I don't think it's any of my
business and I was just flawed when I
read that but 117 people at the time
chimed in and overwhelmingly people were
saying you have to make a call call the
police if you're worried you can be
anonymous and this one particular issue
was uncertain as to what to do and I
thought that was incredibly strange so
the bottom line is this there are some
people out there who are fearful to make
the call and if they know that maybe you
know inadvertently accidentally they say
something
and there could be criminal civil
penalties they may be hesitant and that
one hesitancy could put a child at risk
so thank you I monitor the fire and
police channel for my home city in
Massachusetts a city of 40,000 people
and all day I'm hearing police go to a
certain place because a complaint has
been called in I I don't see that uh we
lack for it um I do know from talking to
police officers in my hometown that
there are people who do call in
anonymously and make false reports their
voices start to get
recognized and eventually action is
taken but it is not on the basis of one
citizen saying that child is running
around without a coat on what's the
matter with the mother and then the cops
come and discover oh it's Billy yeah he
he does that on the school playground
too it's not the mother it's Billy and
oh Mom was looking out the window and
then the process of coming
out where they move is if it is a very
clearly false report from a person who
regularly makes false reports at that
point they make an action they tell me
they do not take an action on
um a a sincere call fire departments get
sent out because somebody saw Steam and
thought it was Smoke there's no penalty
there it was an honest mistake and the
police would make this same
determination it is when it is clearly
malicious and repeatedly by the same
person whose voice is now familiar that
action is taken I don't see that this
would um harm a child I think that if a
child is screaming and one person says I
can't call that in somebody else
probably just has or is about to I also
hear when police are dispatched to a
certain place the phrase receiving
multiple
calls so um I do sympathize for the
concerns of those speaking against the
bill but I'm going to vote for it
because I uh I think the potential harm
to people who are constantly complained
against overrides the theoretical
possibility one innocent child may be
harmed by
non-reporting I don't think those are
anyway equivalents anybody else want to
weigh in yes representative love thank
you Mr chairman uh because we're making
a crime of false reporting uh wouldn't
that crime have to be proven um you know
just to just to add a little more to
what you just said um you know we have
to prove any any crime that and
uh if somebody is constantly doing it if
there's a a divorce going on and you
know they've got uh three family members
doing it uh you know you can you can put
that all together and uh and make a case
but if it's a mistake you know like like
someone mentioned a screaming kid I'm
sure the police or DCF would rather go
out and find out nothing's wrong then go
out and find out that uh this kid has
been abused and um I I just think we're
uh we're we're reaching here uh if we're
going to if we're going to vote against
this this I think this is a good bill
and to say
that the
report was intentionally a false report
intentionality is a fairly High bar to
prove MH so those people who make an
honest mistake do not remotely rise to
the level of
intentionality and in particular when
jurisdictions say there's got to be
several of these intentional false
reports I think that is quite a high bar
counselor yes thank you Mr chairman yes
you're correct uh malice is basically
the intent to injure and so since you
have to show the intent uh a good faith
error you you're not going to be able to
prove that Beyond A Reasonable Doubt in
court and I doubt law enforcement will
bring an action on that basis um you
know once again this is a matter of
intent and that malice standard is very
very high it's a high
bar yes representative please just just
thank you very much uh just for
clarification uh the individual who's
making the phone call I'm wondering if
they're aware of
that well if you're well basically
that's going to be from the intent
that's going to be from the surrounding
facts and circumstances okay and so for
example I think the chairman correctly
points out repeated instances if they're
targeted at the same person uh things
like that
uh ma like I said malice is a really
high bar to prove criminally okay uh
this is not don't confuse it with strict
liability uh there are very few strict
liability almost no strict liability
crimes in the state of New Hampshire
save statutory rape okay uh so that
would be a high bar and not only that we
don't even have to deal with a re able
presumption here uh so I I think you're
safe if you vote this and um I I think
it won't probably deter somebody who was
held bent on malice but it probably
would provide relief for somebody who
was the victim of M uh of repeated false
offenses I so I can support
this representative rice thank you Mr
chairman so I'd like to point out though
that on page two of the bill line five
you have the ability it's already in law
to bring a civil action against someone
from maliciously
reporting that is already in
law yes but this makes it this
criminalizes it that's a different
standard and civil liability is
preponderance of the evidence in most
cases where this is beyond a reasonable
out follow up it's the criminality that
I worry about those that that that is
going to prevent people from calling
malici people who want to do malicious
reporting can still do it
anonymously and you have no way to find
out their information because they're
not giving
it it's my concern is the people that
it's going to prevent from calling
I guess with all due respect if I may
respond Mr chairman I think that's going
to really depend on the level of the
sophistication of the actors uh you know
I think police when you call the police
I think the phone number comes up unless
you've got a block on it or whatever but
I think the chairman correctly points
out that when they get numerous multiple
uh calls uh they're able to figure out
what's going
on I doubt somebody making an honest
mistake would use a burner phone to make
this call
correct
representative
sure
um being a law professor I always trying
to could you stand a little closer to
your mic or could you put your mic a
little closer to your mouth being a law
professor I always resort to research in
the absence of knowledge um uh RSA
6414 already criminalizes as a
misdemeanor of false report to law
enforcement so I'm I'm just not sure we
need putting aside all the other
arguments that have been made on both
sides I'm just not sure we need this
because of RSA
6414 do you have it handy up on your
screen to read to us because I don't
want to walk to the back of the room and
look it up thank you uh I can read it if
okay a person is guilty of a misdemeanor
if he one knowingly gives or causes to
be given false information to a law
enforcement officer with the purpose of
inducing such officer to believe that
another has committed an offense or two
knowingly gives or causes to be given
information to any law enforcement
officer concerning the commission of an
offense or the danger from an explosive
or other dangerous substance knowing
that the offense or danger did not occur
or existing or exists or knowing that he
has no information related relating to
the offense or
charge the offense or danger what
strikes me about this is particularly
the second second paragraph has a
knowingly mental state rather than a
purposely mental state or a malicious
mental state which is which is easier to
prove you just have to know that you are
reporting something falsely um so I I
think there is not perfect overlap
between this and and what's proposed but
I think there's enough overlap that it
concerns me that uh this bill concerns
me in that way so it would be your
testimony that or your um observation
that
6414 pretty much covers what this bill
is trying to do it covers much of what
this bill is trying to do I it's again
it's not a perfect overlap but it's
significant overlap all right to give
you a um a leading
question then
6414 would cover much of the intent of
the bill
without the possible harm that people
have spoken to in your opinion that was
a leading
question yeah which I didn't understand
good but in other words I'll I'll answer
anyway if you want of
course
um now rephrase your question please
asud existing law
covers most of what the bill
wants to do yes but existing law doesn't
have the little negative that people
have been observing about the
bill corre as a deterrent of some people
calling I think dysfunctions as a enough
of a deterrent that we don't need to
have a whole separate statute I I tend
not to be a big fan of plugging little
holes as opposed to plugging big holes
and I think this is a plugging a little
hole given the existence of
6414 okay representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman um the
representative's discussion concerning
uh was it
64 one one uh
that the only thing that concerns me
about
um relating the two is that that 641
specifies to
police in a court of
law if a person
is suing another person for falsely
reporting to DHHS or DCF it could be
argued that 641 only specifies police
and does not include dcy Alpha DH h s
and it could deter the court from uh
making a determination in that
case does that make sense to anybody
else
yes yeah representative marel yes I
appreciate um fellow council's comments
the difference here that I see I Echo
what uh Vice chair says about reports
not other than other than law
enforcement but without this what you do
is you're able uh
I think you're able to raise Reasonable
Doubt about your actions um if you're
going to be able to have conflicting
statutes on point uh so in other words
assume for the sake of argument that uh
law enforcement brings an action based
on 641 okay and says false reports I've
had those cases um now all of a sudden
somebody's asserts that they are immune
from Criminal prosecution because no I
was dealing with child abuse and uh this
is a false report but that's but what
you're doing is you you have two
problems first of all I'd be making an
over breath argument particularly where
I have conflicting statutes one which
IMU immunizes me okay uh because I I'm
making absent this statute I'm making a
report about what I suspect to be child
abuse whatever my true motives are I'm
going to conceal from the police but all
of a sudden when confronted with a
motion to dismiss uh I'm going to I'm
I'm going to have to say that I don't
think you would be able to bring prove
your case Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
because I'm going to assert liability
immunity from liability for a report I
made to law enforcement also DCF so if
I'm calling DCF and not law enforcement
the statute's going to be if it goes out
the other way I think you're looking at
a constitutional issue about over breath
and uh criminalizing whatever the
conduct would be that's how I'm looking
at it so I think you got I I think you
have I I I think it I would agree with
the chairman I think
it does no harm I think it probably
helps rather than hurts and it probably
so that's just my view having her a
defense Council
prosecutor well that makes me nervous um
I in a sense with all due respect I
think you make my point conflicting
statutes create more of a mess than one
statute well then that would be uh that
would be the point of criminalizing it
under both statutes so in other words I
have a client who comes in and says help
I've been charged with uh making a false
report to a police uh RSA 641 whatever
okay and I'm going to say who did you
call you called the police why a
suspected child abuse okay and you're on
a motion to dismiss uh my client is is
is subject to uh is subject to immunity
for making a good faith for making a
report case can't be proven Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt number one number two
is it uh the historic purpose of
Criminal Justice is my right to raise a
reasonable doubt about my client's guilt
and I think a Court's going to have to
come down on that and I'm going to get a
I think I'll get a dismissal on that
basis respectfully
put
wow and Aaron krian said if I was a
lawyer I'd be an appet judge
I'm going to reconsider
that well there it is motion before is
and families motion OTP by
representative Nelson and seconded by
representative sidel if you are for the
motion OTP you will vote Yes if you are
against you will vote
no clerk please call the role chairman
Pon yes
representative D Simone yes
representative rice no representative
McMahan no representative Nelson
yes representative sidel yes
representative love yes representative
coren yes representative marel yes
Representative patrino no Representative
grman no representative sheer no
representative Greg no representative ra
Raymond
no representative
Lucas no representative
Malone
No 7 to n the motion fails
9-7 um against the bill is the another
motion a positive motion that would like
to be
made
what I'm sorry seven to
nine and nine
against uh if I'm correct now I can
entertain an itl
motion represent thank you Mr chairman I
move
itl and seconded by repres resentative
rice the motion is to itl House Bill 243
FN relative to the penalty for false
reports of suspected abuse and neglect
made to the division for children youth
and families the motion is itl made by
representative Petrino seconded by
representative rice if you are for
itl you vote
Yes if you are against itl you vote
no
and a chair can call the role
please chairman pearon this time I am
going to vote Yes
again chairman D Simone Vice chair sorry
no chairman
rice uh representative sorry flashback
represent representative rice yes
representative McMahon
yes representative Nelson
no Representative sidel no
representative l no representative coren
no Representative marel no
representative patrino yes
representative grman
yes representative Sher
yes representative Greg
yes representative
Raymond representative
Lucas
yes representative
Malone
yes the on motion passes 10 to six and
if representative Petrino would write
the committee's report and I'll tell you
a story about when somebody
whoops and voted the wrong way it was
during the old days of
covid and some of you represent um
repres uh remember representative snow
from
Manchester Kendrick snow he was a rep
for he was a rep for a long time and he
was a social worker in Manchester for 40
years and we were all remote except for
me he was sitting in a chair somewhere
and uh called the role and we could look
up and see him asleep remember this is
all
zoomed and I stopped the voting and I
asked representative Weber call his wife
wake him up and you can see in the
picture she's running hey C wake up wake
up you got to vote I vote Yes which he
didn't mean
to and you heard GRS from some and
cheers from the other we got to the end
and I said the chair will entertain a
motion for
reconsideration we passed it unanimous
ly we did it all over again so every
once in a while for purposes of sleep or
what have you it's easy to vote Yes when
you really meant no so there's my story
I'm sticking to it 10 to6 itl motion
passes and this will end our exec
session on House Bill 243 thank you for
the spirited
discussion now what did we do with the
previous one
did I I have a question for the
chair uh not related to the elsat
uh I I I if I need to leave by 10 of
12 um I don't know if you're going to
exec anything more but I don't want to
no um that you need to leave by 10 to 10
to 12 we've got 10 minutes more or 20
minutes more of your company but done
for the morning we're not going to exact
anything else looking at the pain
Expressions on most people's face when I
talk I uh I'm not sure not sure they
want 10 more minutes the second question
is the second question is I can be back
I I have to testy in front of house
Transportation at 1:20 come in and out
as you feel like are you going to EXA
bills this afternoon we'll see I mean if
there ones we don't if we are pretty
much of consensus do we do we have
anything more we likely uh we've got 350
and
335 um then I will be back this
afternoon as close to 1:45 as I can okay
yeah we can we can I mean we really do
try to play fair with each other here so
uh thank you and if we're going to exec
and uh it's going to be that close I
doubt if the bill is going to be that
close we would execute because if it's
that close at least one group if not
both groups want to do some more
thinking and arm twisting and whatnot
but thank you Mr
chair are we going to meet again on
mental health court
stuff yes I would like to I would too uh
maybe after you're done this afternoon
is that too soon or uh it it would be
too soon for me but I'm thinking then
I'll reach I'll reach out to you okay
let's do that thank you
okay
than thank
you by about
qu
11 at
oh thank
you we can be back by
like
e
e e
uh my practice is uh concentration in
events and some and
some German I'm very happy to be here
thank
you uh so this is my first term um I
have been um in foster care when I was a
young person and then I became a foster
parent as an adult I have two of my own
adult children um
that were either still in their lives or
I have another one that
for are still experiencing and how
they're getting stuck um and then it
just sort of goes from there um I'm just
that person that children prevention uh
prevent preventative of abuse of any
type of abuse for children or other
humans um is super important um and I'm
wicked happy to be here
okay I have to put the mic on so
everybody who is live watching this live
stream can hear children and family law
is the best Committee in the entire
State thank you everybody who's
serving the chair wishes to thank
representative grman for her french
fries at lunch
well you were you weren't eating
them see how giving she is the first one
I
stole okay Mr chairman do we want to
talk about this we got three minutes to
go that's your proga you're the working
wait to the end
okay just a word or two because there's
been a lot of confusion over the issue
of
constitutionality and we heard at chairs
and vice chairs meeting this morning the
policy the vice chair woman has her Vice
chair's guidebook and in it it
says one of your duties is no committee
shall Report with a positive
recommendation any bill or resolution
which would if enacted be of violation
of any article of the Constitution of
New Hampshire or of the United States of
America or Grant broad rule making
authority to an agency or Department the
vice chairman or another member of each
committee shall review all pending
legislation and shall advise the members
of all legislation before the committee
which should be reviewed in terms of
this role her review statement to me is
advice it is not a
ruling and when I forwarded that to
everyone it is advice the chair can make
a lot of rulings this is not one of them
I do not rule on the
constitutionality the presumption is
that any bill that comes before us is
constitutional If the vice chair or the
chair
say don't think so that is a personal
opinion not a
ruling when we come to exec the bill if
you don't think the bill is
constitutional then you should vote in
the negative if you do not think it's a
problem you can vote either way
whichever you
wish where this is challenged
initially will be the speaker's office
and we will talk with the speaker if we
have some
concerns after that the people who rule
on the constit tionality of something is
the courts not here so therefore the
chair will not entertain anybody saying
well you've got to stop this because
it's in unconstitutional I cannot make a
ruling that way I can go forward and if
I happen to agree with you I'll vote no
did I miss
anything no Mr chairman I don't think
you you have but I will tell you that
that Mr chairman has made sure that uh
he has more than once asked me to make
sure that any legislation that comes
before us is in my opinion
constitutional uh I have yet to find a
piece of legislation that has come
across our desks that I have an opinion
that it could be deemed
unconstitutional but I just wanted to
reiterate we as let legislators in this
room and take an oath to uphold the
United States
Constitution the state of New
Hampshire's
Constitution those two constitutions we
follow the next thing we follow are
house
rules and then after that comes the laws
that we make and the laws that we amend
and the laws that we
change that's how we are to run our
legislative lives and that to the best
of their ability and we work together as
a
team reasonable people however can have
differences of opinion as to whether a
bill is constitutional or not so I
reiterate she does not make a ruling I
do not make a ruling I will continue
with any bill that has been given to me
I will not stop I am not allowed to stop
when we exec a bill that is when the
question of constitutionality can be
raised by
individuals and an individual believing
it is unconstitutional should vote no
others may vote however they like the
bill or don't like the bill after that
it is out of the committee's control so
I would please ask people who come to
testify uh you may State your
opinion however your opinion is more
likely to be believed if you can point
specifically to where that question in
either Constitution is raised if you
make a broad statement saying it's
unconstitutional you will convince no
one but if you can point to a certain
line item then it is up to each one of
us to decide have you proven your case
you say this line in the Constitution
and this bill are at odds it will be up
to each individual to decide
whether that's true or not so there it
is and everybody up and down the line
apologizes for any confusions I will
have to leave partway through uh about
120ish because I am introducing two of
my bills in the legie no excuse me Muni
County committee um then I'll be back
with that the chair opens House Bill 350
FN a hearing on a bill
requiring that all Family Division
hearings be video and audio recorded and
broadcast live the chair recognizes
representative Caitlyn katab who is
subbing for the prime sponsor
representative
post thank you chairman Pearson and
members of the child and family law
committee for the record my name is
representative kitlyn cab and I am here
to introduce this bill for the prime
sponsor onor Lisa post who could not be
here when this bill was initially
introduced the purpose of the bill was
to provide transparency into the family
court proceedings and to have audio and
video recordings of the
non-confidential proceedings in the
Family
Division however after it was
implemented I worked with rep post to
talk with the court about it and there
were really quite a few concerns with it
and so we'd like to work with the court
to potentially amend this into a pilot
program instead and I want to give some
specifics on what those concerns were so
for example there might be private bench
conversations and there is no staff in
many of the courtrooms that are
available to mute the
microphones and we wouldn't want those
private convos to be
recorded and also you may have prosay
parties in the family cases that may
reveal some of their child's private
confidential medical information that we
wouldn't want to be
included and with 32 Court locations
they're just there aren't staff in each
of those courtrooms so the purpose of
the pilot program would be to see how
often these are requested how hard is
how difficult is it for this to happen
test out the equipment that that might
be used for it to see is this it does
this equipment work
well they would like lik have to do some
sort of potential redactions as these
are requested if there were to be
confidential information revealed within
them
so uh we're still kind of trying to work
through what might work so if possible
I'd like to request if we could if you
guys could not exec the bill yet to give
a little bit of time to try and work
together with the court to see if
there's a potential pilot we might be
able to write
recommend because this is an early Bill
uh we've got to get it out the door here
on March 6th so for your scheduling
purposes
um we would probably execute on the 6th
the previous week is New Hampshire
school vacation week and we're pretty
well booked up for the next couple of
weeks anyway so if you can get it here
by March 6 we'll take a look at it thank
you to take any questions
thank you I've already heard some
questions on this
and aren't hearing them
now
okay chair recognizes representative
Erica
Leon thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Erica Leon I represent
the town of as well as a couple of the
members of this committee so I'm glad to
be in front of all of you
today I am a co-sponsor of this bill
because right now there's not a lot of
confidence that everything that happens
in the courtroom actually makes it to
the record um I had a family contact me
stating that their parole officer had
testified that they had actually come
and visited a child right after they had
supposedly assaulted the child the
parole officer came in spoke in the
courtroom and that never actually make
made it into the record um there's been
a number of times where what we hear
from people isn't the same as the record
and we need to have a way to determine
what is true and what is not right now
we're stuck in a lot of um he said she
said I know that that's something that
this committee deals with a lot but I
think it's absolutely critical that
we're able to that there is able to be a
record made of the proceedings
that's not subject to the same human
error that minutes can be subject to
because we're talking about families and
we're talking about people's children
we're talking about potentially having
exculpatory evidence that is heard and
stated in the courtroom but is not
entered into the record leaving children
separated from their parents when there
really is no good reason for that to
happen because somebody has come in and
said no I saw that child after that
incident and there's somebody that this
state in this court the state and the
Court's trust because they are a parole
officer so I'm interested to see what
representative kutab has done with this
bill as a co-sponsor I hadn't heard
anything yet about this um what I do
want to do is make sure that we have the
information and we can stop we can stop
this
um we can stop trying to have to resolve
these disputes When people's children
are taken from them without as much
information as those families want to
make available to us because if they
choose to have this information recorded
they're already willing to have it known
that some the state's trying to take
their children from them they're already
ready to have it known all of the awful
things that will be said in those
hearings and they think that it's
important enough to be able to do that
publicly so that they can make sure that
Justice is served and I think that we
owe them the ability to make sure that
what is said in court is recorded in
court and that children aren't separated
from families unnecessarily and also
that families aren't kept with parents
who are causing harm either this goes
both ways we need to make sure that we
are prioritizing the children both in
their safety and in their security of
staying with loving families so with
that I'd be happy to take any
questions representative
rice thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question nowhere in here do I
see a time limit as to how long the
Judiciary is supposed to hold on to
these uh
recordings and what and then determining
how long they have to hold on to these
do they have the storage capacity to
keep these and how much more is that
going to cost us well thank you for
those questions they're very good points
and since it looks like there's an
already amendment in the works that
would be good to make sure that we
include in this as well however it moves
forward and I appreciate you raising
those concerns because those are
important thank you representative patri
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm just curious as to the rationale
behind the live broadcasting of the
proceedings um thank you for that
question um we also have the issue where
if somebody's able to watch then they're
able to see what's going on
um it's always a challenge to figure out
how to do this but if a family wants to
say this is what's happening to me I
want to have eyes on what is happening
in court that's why you would have a
live broadcast as you know here we have
do have a time delay so there I'm sure
that I would expect that this would be
subject to administrative rules um
assuming that DCF I guess this isn't DCF
but I actually couldn't even find the
DCF administrative rules which is
troubling um but this would be subject
to administrative rules and by doing
that they would be able to have
something like perhaps there's an
emergency pause button just like
security has here if something goes
wrong with the recording that there may
be some times when they say well we need
to stop this this ride right here um and
I would be amimal to that idea of being
able to pause something if something
truly potentially harmful is happening
but also where it continues
along representative rice thank you Mr
chairman thank you again for taking my
question
so these hearings have a lot of
confidential information a lot of times
they have to do with children and I'm
just concerned that live broadcasts or
information to the public out there
could cause a child irreparable harm
especially by classmates or um you know
their peers that sees this going on and
then they're getting backlash how would
we prevent that from happening well
thank you for the question I wish we
weren't in a position where we needed to
have this right now we also have the
irreparable harm of having children
taken from their parents when there's
fatory evidence presented in court
saying that the allegations cannot in
fact be true yet that child is still
separated from their parents and from
their family and from their support
system and sometimes even from their
schools um I wish we weren't at the
situation where we're looking at live
streaming these court cases but families
are being failed on both sides of the
coin both um when children are harmed
and when children are taken needlessly
because that causes harm too um it's not
a perfect solution but neither is taking
a child when when they should not be
taken from their
home representative
Coran thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here um I hear you saying
that this will be an optin type of
situation and not necessarily recording
every single
case um thank you for the question as I
was
[Music]
looking that was my understanding as we
were working through the langage of the
bill that this would be on request of
the families because if this isn't on
request of any of the parties involved
then that would be a huge violation of
privacy however allowing a family to opt
into that is what my intention was in
co-sponsoring the bill and that was
language that I had reviewed um it's
possible that it's possible that I had
read the intentions more than what the
language was but I in no way intend for
anything to be made public unless
somebody is standing there and saying I
I want this to be broadcast because I
people I want people to know the truth
of this
process when I look at lines uh 12 and
13 of the bill um The Family Division
shall broadcast live if requested to do
so by the
plaintiff or defendant or named
representative that sounds like one
party can request it and it will be so
uh I don't see that this means if one
party objects it shall not be
so um thank you for finding that section
and then if you look below that it says
the presiding judge shall Grant the
request unless the opposing party show
or representative shows by a
preponderance of the evidence that the
broadcast is more likely than not to
cause specific specific irreparable harm
to a party or witness and upon that
showing then they wouldn't show those
parts that would cause harm um and that
the judge will state the basis for that
but that person has to prove
preponderance of
evidence is what I'm reading um I think
that it's important to have some sort of
guard rails because if you were able to
say I think that somebody might might
bully this kid if they find out that
their family is in family court and
right now you have a family that's
trying to stay together because of
potentially false allegations and they
have somebody in order to um dispute
that with uh very clear evidence
especially somebody that it would be
normally respected by the court that the
other side shouldn't be able to silence
that just because they don't want that
part heard we are in the situation where
very well-intentioned people are trying
to do the best they can for families and
families are trying to also keep
themselves Inta intact there will always
be emotions there will always be
personal feelings that that come into
play as much as people try and stay
neutral and unbiased and um because most
of the people involved in these family
courts and in this really really truly
want the best for these children
um they may sometimes not see things the
same way as another person would or
another party would so having the judge
specifically say why something won't be
broadcast will give us much clearer
guidelines around that and have that
transparency representative D
Simon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question and thank you
again for coming here today uh you this
bill talks about uh recording and
broadcasting the proceedings to whom
will these proceedings be
broadcast on lines 19 and 20 the link to
the live broadcast shall be available to
the public through the clerk's office at
the location where the proceeding takes
place followup thank you will you take a
followup yes thank you for taking a
followup in that particular case um that
it's going to be broadcast to all of
those people um if a person who is to be
cross-examined by uh one or the the
other attorney and that person says I
don't want my testimony broadcast what
happens then um well thank you for that
question the point is we're trying to
make sure that children are only removed
from the families for good reason um
when you're looking at this if they're
if they're already testifying then
that's already known that they are
testifying the question is why would
they why would you not want to have your
testimony shared if you are truly
speaking on the best interest of the
children and best interest of the child
because we understand that it we
understand that there's judgment calls
that come into play but transparency
around this is very important and that
helps for other people to understand
where that line is and understand what
is and isn't
acceptable representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so understanding
the sensitive nature of Family Court
proceedings also understanding the fact
that sometimes people who are complicit
in abusive behaviors don't understand
that what the judicial branch has is a
very specific thing that's very case
specific and I worry about the there is
a question I worry about the two
branches here we are the legislative and
they're the judicial and they are in the
trenches covering each one of these
cases has it been thought to bring this
to to the judicial branch to maybe do
what other states do and have it's kind
of like a when you're a student teacher
or something they have somebody sit in
and observe the judges to see what's
going on and it's a surprise so it's
kind of like an audit they don't know
but that actually examines what each
judge is doing to help with that
judicial oversight versus the
legislature trying to get involved in
the judicial branch and telling them how
to mitigate very sensitive situations
well uh thank you for that idea that is
also another interesting approach I do
have to say that just because you want
to have something happen in public
doesn't mean that it's always
comfortable um TSA when I've had to be
searched and even um in areas that I
don't want to I don't go into another
location even if it might expose a
little bit more of me than I would like
I would rather have that done in public
just because sometimes it feels better
to make sure that there are other eyes
observing what's happening we're all
working the best that we can in order to
do to implement the laws and and pass
the laws that are most protective of
everybody who's involved however we also
need to make sure that that that bance
That Power Balance as well is not
leading to a point where families are
being are losing their children when
they shouldn't and also that if when
people are able to see those power
balances when somebody is enabling
enabling this sort of abuse I think that
people try understanding that you know M
Mrs Jones actually was doing the wrong
thing Mrs Jones was having it so that
her child was being subjected to harm
and by Mrs Jones not standing up to that
that is truly harm while in somebody may
not intend to make themselves an example
of what not to do that's what happens
when you choose to have something done
publicly and when people are able to see
it it's a lot easier to say no that's
not you may think that this was wrong
but in fact what you're doing is
something that is not acceptable to
people in New Hampshire it's not a
acceptable way of raising your children
and that is something that we all see as
abuse and once you get to the point
where that can be broadcast and that can
be shared then you get past the question
of well do I trust this person do I
trust what they're saying because so
much of this dispute comes down to who
we
trust followup representative Greg thank
you Mr chairman would you believe that
I've sat in on many many court cases um
and watched the high the high level of
emotion and watch people say things or
do things that they wouldn't normally do
in public that had that been broadcasted
they would probably struggle to then
find a job or anything else
after well that was would you believe
right um that was a what you believe yes
but I also do know that there's people
who massively struggle with having their
children taken when there's not a good
reason for it and you and I sat through
sat in the subcommittee on uh DCF and we
did hear very emotional testimony um
some that I I also saw was getting into
that emotional area but the question is
if people want to have views into what
is happening and why their child is
being removed I think that that is
reasonable
thank you representative Raymond uh
thank you uh Madam chair uh Vice
chairwoman and thank you for taking my
question um my question is about the
rights of the child um to privacy I'm
thinking about the hundreds of cases in
the family court that I've sat in where
therapeutic records where medical
records and where evidence of things
like sexual abuse um have been discussed
in the courtroom and my question is who
gets to decide where the child's right
to privacy is um and if the parents
disagree on whether or not they think
it's a good idea for their minor child's
information to go out who where's the
protection for like the best interest
part of this this bill because I'm
seeing preponderance of the evidence
that it would hurt them but where's the
best interest that is usually guides
most of our stuff well thank you for the
question um I I would support giving a
veto of that child of saying that I
don't want any of this broadcast but if
the child is sitting there saying why am
I not able to see my dad why was why was
I removed from the home why is this
happening because my dad hasn't done
anything to hurt me and they don't
understand why it's happened that that
child should be able to say no I may
only be seven but I know that my dad
didn't do anything wrong and I want this
to be broadcast to make sure I can get
back with him know if you give it to a
veto power of the child then we get into
a situation where at least in some of
these some of these cases uh we can be
in a situation where we're not
separating these families honestly I
think that I I think that I think that
that might make sense because I do agree
that you don't want to have your dirty
laundry tossed out in public unless
there is a very very strong reason to do
so but I do I have spoken with people
where it does seem very clear that there
was a violation and if there was if they
had been able to have a recording and
and have that information I think that
everybody would see how clear it was or
I would know that the wool's been pulled
over my eyes but either way somebody who
wanted to make that public we would
understand what was happening thank you
uh representative rice and then
representative Nelson thank you madam
chair thank you for taking another
question so in section four of the bill
it states copies of video and audio
recording shall be made available by the
clerk's office blah blah blah um so
anybody just go in and grab the video of
the private and personal hearing that
was just held that may not have anything
to do with the the family cuz there's no
limitations here uh thank you for
bringing that up that would be a good
limitation to add so I appreciate you
helping make it better thank
you representative
Nelson thank you madam Vice chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question are there other states who are
uh where this is um in practice um thank
you for the question I don't know and
thank you madam
chair representative
Gman thank you madam
chair thank you for coming here today
um so divorce proceedings family court
it's it can already be
contentious in situations where the two
parties don't
agree what would occur
um if you look at this it says that if
one party asked to have that then the
judge would need to say that there's a
reparable
harm they would need to prove right so
it would be another they would first
need to prove it and then the judge
would order it thank you yes I I can
read that that's what's in here and I do
know that there is an amendment that is
coming so since there is an idea of an
amendment assuming that it's it sounds
that it that the amendment was supported
by the prime sponsor
so if the prime SP sponsor has an
amendment um then I think that it's
helpful to highlight some of the issues
and challenges with this language so
that she can incorporate this into her
Amendment but um and I thank you for
highlighting
that look forward to the amendment
thanks representative love thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question uh you me mentioned that the
probation officer had gone to court and
testified and somehow that testimony
came up missing um would you and you
know there's a lot of opposition to the
the privacy of of people here uh would
the the sponsors be amendable to uh
amending this to just uh it it shall be
recorded and those recordings are
available to the the
parties um thank you that is an
interesting idea where then if that is
available and it can be referenced um
that that that may be one way to address
the privacy concerns
any further questions representative
marel thank you for taking my call um
question sorry uh nobody's perfect
um out of curiosity um you're aware that
audio recordings are made of these
proceedings as they go correct I'm
correct I am aware that we did pass that
um the part of the question I think I am
aware that we have passed that my
question is
um that there's also been issues with
the audio recording seeming like they've
been cut off from time to time I've
heard that before I I I'm more giving
that general information of it because
it's if you have a video recording it's
a lot easier to see the Stutter Step if
the video goes out as opposed to an
audio recording going out okay follow-up
question followup thank you um because
you can order uh in my experience also
ordering them for appeals is is that
when you contact in New Hampshire you
contact escribers and you can order an
audio uh recording of it and you can
also uh also get a written transcript of
the proceedings um I guess what I'm
trying to
understand if there's going to be a
break in the audio there'll be a break
in the in the transcript as well
wouldn't there uh correct and that is
actually one of the issues that having a
video recording where you you can see if
suddenly it goes from me speaking here
and then it starts again with me sitting
in the other chair next to it it's clear
that is not a continuous recording in an
audio recording that's not the case I'm
not trying to claim malfant I'm
talking thank you that actually I I was
about to say that I'm talking about when
there's technical problems and nobody is
intended to cut off when nobody is
intended to cut off the recording but it
happens from time to time because we're
all human and worse we use computers and
those they don't always like us so
sometimes there's unavoidable reasons
why there is a break in the continuity
and that doesn't mean that somebody's
doing something wrong it just means that
there's a break in the
continuity okay thank you representative
rice thank you madam shair thank you
again so my next question is going to be
what prevents someone from getting these
recordings with the children in the
thing and then they're posted to social
media and all that is there going to be
limitations as to what they can do with
these
recordings well thank you for the
question I think that that is a very
good idea
to it's a matter of putting the
guardrails around that so nobody was
allowed to even speak about their case
in dcyf until recently because there was
a gag order on on some of what was
happening um so we do have some of those
issues around that transparency and I
know we're all working together to
better better improve the lives of both
Children and Families but then there are
some hurdles along the way I don't think
that this should be shared maliciously
on social media but I also think that if
you have video that your parole officer
saw your child 5 minutes after you
supposedly punched them in the face and
the parole officer says no I visited
them and they were fine and they were
watching a movie at the time and nothing
was wrong and if you still have your
trial taken based on testimony that's
that's put against um that that has a
parole officer testifying on your behalf
at a certain point shouldn't you be
allowed to share that on social media um
I would hope that we aren't having
things like that happening I'm I'm kind
of hoping for the recordings so that I
can know if somebody is selling me a
bill of goods but if this is actually
happening that's a huge problem it's a
huge silent problem and it's something
that we can address through greater
transparency and I appreciate all the
work you've done trying to keep Kids
Safe I really do
seeing no further questions thank you
for your time and testimony thank
you next out call Mary
Krueger Mary you've asked for five
minutes welcome thank you um Madame Vice
chair and thank you members of the
committee my name is Mary Krueger I'm an
attorney with New Hampshire legal
assistance um we are a Statewide civil
Legal Services Program helping people in
poverty with various uh basic needs we
operate our domestic violence advocacy
project which I supervise and we um
represent High lethality victims of
domestic violence sexual assault
stalking in protection order cases
divorce and parenting cases um we are
asking that this Comm committee um in
expedient to legislate this bill um and
I have prepared written testimony I
apologize that I did have some issues
with the copy machine so there's blank
pages interspersed throughout whereas I
was trying to double space a double page
so I completely muffed it up and so
forgive me for that um but um you'll see
that there are really three main reasons
why we would oppose this um one we
believe it will harm children um who are
already negatively impacted when parents
are separating and I'll point out that
um we just heard a lot of testimony
about dcyf proceedings when I read this
um hadn't even occurred to me that that
was an intentioned was to um broadcast
live confidential DCF abuse and neglect
or parent ter termination of parental
rights from parental rights cases which
are already confidential cases under
statute and this specifically excludes
confidential cases from being um
broadcast um if this work enacted so it
it would not even uh fix the situation
that we just heard about because those
would be excluded entirely so I read
this to apply to divorce parenting and
protection order cases in the Family
Court um and when I see that I do see
that one party could decide to request
to have it live streamed there's no
guard rails whatsoever on that um and
the uh
limitation that's placed on that where
by a preponderance of the evidence the
other party who doesn't want it live
streamed um would have to demonstrate
irreparable harm to them or a witness um
and then the court would need to decide
which portion of the case would not be
broadcast so this would be broadcast
live streamed anybody could download
that broadcast there's no it's going to
be there really forever right it's out
there on the internet there's no
hauling it back um I also think even if
the court W didn't Grant the request to
live stream when we have the video
recordings it just makes it that much
more easy for someone to go request that
video recording and then take pieces of
that videotape and post selective cuts
um on Tik Tok or uh Facebook or
Instagram or you name it whatever you
know uh YouTube um social media that you
can think of and it's gone it's there
it's out there um I do think that that
is a major concern especially for kids
uh because they they are already by the
policy of the family court um trying the
court is trying to set a stage when
parents are separating to protect
children the first thing that families
do is go to a first appearance and you
probably all know about this um but this
is the opportunity where the parents
come hear from the judge about how to
behave in the best interest of their
children to try to work towards
co-parenting every single parent has to
go to a child impact seminar that
seminar is um uh I think it's like 3
hours that they sit and they learn all
about how to be um thinking about their
children's best interests as they
separate to try to calm things down um
children should be protected from what
happens in the courtroom children will
not be protected from what happens in
the courtroom if this bill passes um one
minute and then the last thing is I
think that for domestic violence
survivors this will be a barrier to
wanting to file protection orders
because they will be concerned that this
could be live streamed this will be a
threat that could be held over their
head to not go seek the help that they
need um there's several ways that a an
abuser could coer a victim If This Were
enacted so I just want to reiterate that
we're asking this to be itl I can't
believe that the court would want to
Pilot this honestly I don't think that's
an amendment that we would support
either thank you thank you Miss Krueger
any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you I'll call forward uh
Mr Dana alre he has for 3
minutes good afternoon good afternoon
Madam chair and members of the committee
uh for the record my name is Dana alre
uh I have three exhibits that are being
passed
around uh the
first uh is an email from from
escribers uh regarding the preparation
of a court
transcript uh where they're going to
deliberately leave out uh judicial
misconduct and escribers tells the
judicial branch quote of course we are
not going to transcribe that however the
ordering party has also ordered the
audio uh second is an email from uh
former chief administrative Circuit
Court Judge David King uh indicating
he's fully aware of that and
third is
the uh August 26 2022 partial deposition
of Judge David King uh where he's under
oath and uh being asked uh about the
transcript and uh these are all widely
available online for anyone watching
just uh go to judg king.com or Google
judg King uh
deposition uh so uh with that said as to
the need for the
bill uh I would sort of repeat most of
what rep Lon said uh but you already
heard it from her so I don't have to uh
so let me drill down on the specific
need here and some of Eternal
Mars sir how do I your your name forgive
me Markel
comments uh on the accuracy of the
record
um what's very problematic here is when
uh we're
simply
creating an inaccurate record
deliberately to cover up judicial
misconduct deliberately
and if you look at uh page 26 uh this
transcript is redacted uh the deposition
is redacted I've been unable to get the
whole thing um if you look at what's
supposed to be page 26 lines 12 to 16 uh
you'll note Five Points number one judge
king was under oath during the
deposition number two it appears that
judge king knowingly lied by stating
that he informed the judicial conduct
committee about his findings regarding
the transcript when in fact he did no
such thing uh point three uh it appears
he intentionally did not disclose his
findings to the judicial conduct
committee fully aware that his
deposition statement was false uh number
four you have about one minute yes very
material thank you cost signant delays
lasting several years which necessitated
the New Hampshire Supreme Court's orders
for multiple revisions of the initially
falsified transcript and uh point five
uh he made this false statement in a
legal context where he wasn't under an
obligation to tell the truth and so
that's just uh
to
uh address the accuracy of the record
and just a few other comments on the
domestic violence piece to respond I'll
give you about 30 seconds okay is that
fair that's fair thank you um I was most
recently denied the opportunity to film
a family court proceeding at the request
of a domestic violence
victim uh because the perpetrator uh
said no even when I went through the
standard channels that exist today to do
that and it's my understanding that's
highly irregular that was last on uh
January
15th uh if you want I can give you more
details but you said 30 seconds so uh um
let's leave it at that and I'm happy to
take
questions thank you any questions for Mr
albre seeing none thank you very much
for your testimony and the handouts
thank
you next I'd like to call um The
Honorable Betty gay you've asked for
four minutes I'm going to ask you to
take your seat and then I have some
business to take care of please
uh it is now 1:45 we are scheduled for a
hearing on House Bill 335 at 1:45 so I'm
going to recess the hearing on 3 House
Bill
350 for an
announcement I'm going to open the
hearing on House Bill
335 at 1:45 and I'm going to recess it
until we finish the last three speakers
on House Bill 350 with without objection
may we
proceed thank you I will recess the
hearing on House Bill
335 and we will get back to it as soon
as we finish House Bill 350 with the
Indulgence of all those who have come to
testify we are now in recess of uh House
Bill 335 and I will reopen the hearing
on House Bill 350 thank you honorable
gay you may proceed thank you madam
chair this is not one of those fun bills
where everybody says oh thank goodness
we finally have this I've been meaning
to do it I have submitted this bill in
another form twice because we found out
that if there's a breakdown in
communication deliberately between
people who are in family court and
supposedly it is for protection privacy
protection but that means that people
don't get to know each other's troubles
that are happening in court and it
became apparent to me as a rep when I
was appealed to by victims of bad
practices in court when they would look
forward to getting their excuse me their
recordings that they paid for all all
transcript you can buy the recordings
and they're very affordable like $35
paying for a transcript you're talking
into thousands so lots of people are
priced right out of the market they
can't and they're not legally permitted
to make their own
transcripts which I think is very
unfair um so one of the problems is they
would look forward to getting their
their their recordings because the judge
said something that they absolutely
should not have said and then they find
out it's been
deleted so if one person said that to me
you know I'd be a little suspicious no
several people have told me that so
we're not talking about a friendly
discussion on policy to change Family
Court plenty of people who are employed
by the court do not like the changes so
we are in a hostile environment to come
in and say we need some changes here to
make the playing field Fair
uh
historically recordings are edited and
as the man who just testified he has
written proof an email from transcribers
where they say very openly well we clean
up I'm using my own terms we clean up
what the judge says if they think it's
not worthy of a judge they'll make it
nicer so we finally had a person who
could watch the judge so they had the
transcribers cleaning up the language we
also have a person who was watching that
just happened the judge wasn't behind a
solid a solid uh you know you could see
their feet she could see him turning it
off and on and that would explain why
there were Clicks in the recording when
he was saying something like you're not
going to like this or something else
that wasn't really polite he turned the
recording off this has to stop and if
people can make their own recordings I
don't for me I don't have to have it uh
paid paid played out to the world I just
want people to have the right to make
the
recordings and then they can still buy
the recording that's still the official
but if their recording does match the
official recording I think we'll see a
change in the behavior of the people
processing the recordings because there
should be P punishment or lose the
contract if you're going to do
that so I think if a crime against a
child 30 seconds if a crime against a
child is being
discussed Family Court probably isn't
the right place it probably should be in
criminal court so I think for to protect
the child the truth has to come out and
the recording is a necessary part of the
truth coming
out thank you thank you any questions
for Miss
gay seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony
today next I'll call uh Gail drat
in the interest of time Mr robat you've
asked for 3 to five minutes how about if
we break it even at 4 it'll be quick
yeah thank you m' um so Gail drat for
the record amher New Hampshire I'm in
support of this bill part one article 8
of our constitution in ensures that
magistrates officers of the Court are
accountable to the people our courts are
open and assessible to the
people Family Division rule again is
open to the public hearings in the
Family Division are
open to the public unless otherwise
specified by State Statute or order
cases under 169c protection acts provide
appropriate restrictions for that so
those can be restricted um
um audio and video recording of Family
Court proceedings will benefit both
litigants and Court officials by
providing a precise accurate and
accessible record of the
proceedings this ensures that all
statements testimony and judicial
rulings are clearly documented reducing
the risk of misunderstandings and
misrepresentations for litigants it
creates an official and transparent
record that is crucial in the event of
an appeal ensuring fairness in the
judicial process for court officials
recordings provide an efficient way to
review and pro proceedings without the
need for extensive transcripts
ultimately reducing costs this method
also promotes accountability consistency
and Family Court decisions audio video
recordings protect all parties to the
case it protects the courts and the
litigants um and I just want to point
out there was questions about other
states doing this Nevada are audio video
recorded in every County
and um you fill out a form you request
the thing the recording on a CD or a
memory stick so they also are recorded
in Kentucky so I don't know you may want
to somebody look into that and see or
they're going to email me some
information on it so I'm happy to take
questions if you have
any representative
Nelson sorry she wasn't
thank you thank you madam Vice chair and
thank you for taking my question I I
will look into it some more I haven't
and thank
you is that um live broadcast permission
or um audio I think it can be that's
just audio video that they can
request okay thanks so I'll give you the
contact information
yeah seeing no further questions thank
you for your testimony I have one final
card it's from Aon KGAN who has made
herself available for
questions does anybody have any
questions for Miss
KGAN sorry just introducing myself for
the folks at home general counsel for
the court system I was just going to ask
you to do that thank you for introducing
yourself and and coming forward any
questions uh representative McMahon
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the question do we need this
bill as a member of the judicial branch
I would always defer to the legislature
on whether to uh pursue a bill or not I
would not want to advise you um I do
understand and I think you hear it there
are different interests there's
transparency and then there's privacy
and those can come into pretty direct
conflict and those are those are very
difficult to balance so I don't envy you
uh the job that you have um there are
some options people have now uh they can
request to record or they can uh seek a
copy of the video surveillance the
security video surveillance which does
not have audio but it is a a form of
video um I understand the purpose of
this to be to to try to create more
transparency as the court system we want
people to have confidence in the work
that the courts do um but we also want
people to feel safe and secure in Family
Division and feel that they can discuss
some matters that are very very intimate
and often very private uh that's a
challenging balance I appreciate the
conversation that I've had with um some
of the sponsor of this legislation to
make some changes including potentially
not being live potentially being
recorded rather than live so that things
could be redacted if they needed to be
um starting with one courthouse uh as a
as a scaling measure to see how it were
to go um and I think also considering
more judicial discretion was something
that the the sponsors were thinking of
as well to to deal with individual
circumstances so it's it's been a very
good dialogue but I would I would not
want to comment on whether the legisl
determination should be whether to move
forward with the bill or not one one
followup Madam chair followup thank
you relative to the Genesis of why the
bill is here can you comment on are
Judges selectively revising the records
after the fact I have no information
suggesting that I do know that there is
an instance where a judge under their
breath said an exploitive and the
describers did not know whether to
transcribe an exploitive or or not the
person was fired um as a result of that
incident thank you very much thank you
madam
chair thank you uh representative Greg
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here taking my question so I just
wanted to know if is there any kind of a
judicial review or anything if a judge
Cuts an entire section out or is there
any um a check and balance on that kind
of stuff it it's a great question in um
in our Superior Courts if you've
traveled to them you may know that there
are Court monitors who are listening the
entire time and they're very careful and
they're checking the records our circuit
courts are just not staffed that way um
typically it is just the judge and a
court security officer in the courtroom
and the court security officer in
addition to scanning for potential
security issues flicks on the record
when they see the judge come back to the
bench and flicks it off as the judge is
leaving I don't think it's impossible
that someone's made an error I don't
have a reason to think it's something
other than an error but typically when
the judge is not present the record is
not on and people in the courtroom are
speaking freely without being worried
about being
recorded representative
love thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um you know in
talking to constituents of mine uh the
the family courts are the the confidence
in is at an all-time low uh we need
transparency would the would the
judicial system be uh adverse to to
doing like I asked um repres
representative Lyon to to to streamline
this to uh to just the people can get
the the litigants can get copies of the
of the proceedings so if they have to go
on and and you know uh go to Superior
Court or whatever you uh they'll have it
at a at a reasonable cost you heard U
representative gay uh talk about
thousands for for um transcripts um you
know we've got to do better than that
especially with so many people are doing
prosay and that's that's because they're
broke you're completely right that most
people who appear in the Family Court
appear without a lawyer and that this is
a very intimidating process and often
this is the worst thing that will ever
happen to them they're getting divorced
they're the subject of an abuse and
neglect case they have to seek a civil
protective order this is maybe the worst
day of their lives um and they're coming
without a lawyer to a court system
that's a very intimidating process um
completely want people to have
confidence so we want to be partners in
in the measures that legislators are
taking to increase that confidence um
people can record if that may be an
option for
them I think I would just need more
legislative guidance on whether This
subsumes Confidential hearings and how
that would be protected or whether this
is only not confidential proceedings
whether the court is allowed to order
that they not disseminate it or whether
they can't order that because the
legislature has made a determination
that it is a it is something that can be
distributed so I think that there are
things we can do to instill more
confidence but I would still expect that
the record is turned off when the court
is not sitting so it may be that you
experience some of these same concerns
that folks have that the record is off
for a period of time um what I might
suggest to someone if they are worried
about that is to get the security video
and see that it'll run through because
it has no audio and they'll be able to
see the full run through period which is
a process that they can request right
now followup yes ma'am um what would a a
recording without any a do for anybody
it would show you if you match it with
the audio which you can also order you
can see what what periods of time are
not recorded So when that the judge is
Off the Bench that there's not a witness
speaking and I know that that's labor
intensive but there there's at least
some potential check there um but your
point about transcripts and the costs I
mean you're right they can be expensive
uh this being New Hampshire uh we
completely outsourced the transcript
process to a private company which does
them at order as people order them they
pay for them it is not a service we do
in house so it's not a situation where
we have the transcript and we're not
giving it to someone we don't have it
it's a private company that's making it
on request as people order
it any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your time thank you have a great
day with that I will close the hearing
um on House Bill 350 FN
and I will open the hearing on House
Bill 335 FN at this
time and ask all those here to testify
on House Bill 335 to uh
forgive the uh lateness of opening this
hearing and the first person I'm going
to call is the only pink card that I
have at the
moment um um representative Caitlyn
katab can you please introduce yourself
and thank you for
coming thank you madam chairwoman and
members of the children family law
committee for the record my name is
representative kein cab and I am
introducing House Bill 335 on behalf of
the Prime sponsor Lisa post who could
not be here
today I have just passed around an
amendment
from rep post which all of the
co-sponsors are also on the
amendment the biggest thing that this
amendment is seeking to change we have
to speak on the bill not the amendment
okay I'm just I'm going to reference the
main bill as I as I talk it's one word
change just so that we no so I'm sorry
ma'am no so um the
when the main bill was written the
intent was that the
court
May um order a risk assessment within 14
days in certain
circumstances when um
they are
worrying that there may be some sort of
a family conflict or that the child may
be showing signs of abuse or rejecting
that parent that they may be able to
order it unfortunately what had
originally come out said shell and so
this amendment changes it to May so when
you're
looking on the original bill it is um on
line 8 that word shell is being changed
to May by the
amendment I do think that it's really
important that
we're able to give this tool to the
court it's enabling legislation it's not
requiring anything this is if the judge
feels like this is a necessary thing to
do that they're able to do this and I'm
happy to take any questions on this
Bill thank you for your testimony any
questions for the
representative um representative Raymond
and this will be on the bill only okay
thank you I think my thank you m uh M
chairwoman I think my question applies
uh just fine for that so thank you for
taking my question um my question is
about who will be doing these
assessments um is there an anticipated
like court appointed pool of people to
the assessments um is it the can's
assessment that dcyf uses or is it up to
the participants to identify their own
therapist and then have this assessment
done oh and is there a standard
assessment that exists that would be
given or is it completely up to
individual providers that was a bunch of
questions
sorry thank you for the questions
representative Raymond so the bill is
specifying that it does have to be a
clinical psychologist who is
credentialed in this specific area um
and so it would it would be somebody
that would have to be credentialed in
this in this specific area it wouldn't
be somebody that's a
court uh employee so to speak it would
it would be a it would be a private
provider um
and we're leaving it open to the judge
rather he rather they want to recommend
a certain provider or the parties
perhaps want to agree on a provider on
their own um again this is a a May type
thing so I think it's really important
that we leave that leeway up because
perhaps there is already a provider
associated with the family that the
child is really comfortable with and
would prefer to use rather than a
stranger that may be suggested that the
child doesn't know particularly if
there's already some ongoing trauma of
some sort we wouldn't want to kind of
ret traumatize the child by having to go
and talk to somebody different follow up
thank you followup uh thank you um so is
there a definition for what is
incorporated what is included in a risk
assessment yes so that would be
starting at line
okay thank you all set well I'm just
wondering where the definition came
from like is this a is this a common
thing that's in like follow is that your
followup yes that's my followup to
clarify the followup it is my
understanding from the sponsor that this
language she worked with a psychologist
on this language that is familiar with
this very familiar with this field uh is
an expert in the field and provided this
language based
on
typical how this is typically
done thank you representative rice thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question who's going to pay for
this thank you for the question
representative rice so in the bill it is
requiring that the cost shall be equally
borne by the
parties followup followup
I have a followup and I lost it dang it
would you like me to come back to you
yeah please okay representative
Nelson Madam I Madam Vice chair I uh
representative Sher was waiting before
me so I'm glad to I apologize I did not
see representative Sher I I do best I
can to hide you did a great job thank
you and thank you representative Nelson
um uh
uh I have a daughter who's a clinical
psychologist uh and I'm I'm aware
how uh how
many how many different kinds of
Specialties there are for clinical
psychologist uh my concern is in a state
like New Hampshire where there's not
even as many clinical psychologists as
there are in Rhode Island where my
daughter works that we're creating in
the mind of a court the possib the the
re the reality that boy I can have a
clinical psychologist help me make this
decision when in fact it's not the case
do you know if the prime sponsor has any
sense of whether there are there is a
large enough pool to make this
practical thank you for the question
representative sure it is my
understanding that there while there are
not an overabundance of these providers
there are several of these providers
within the state in different different
geographical areas of the state followup
just followup um what if one of the
parties can't afford a clinical
psychologist what happens then thank you
for the question so this is a this is a
May type of a thing so if the judge
deems that hey the parties can't afford
it then in that case he wouldn't be
ordering it this is not I don't think
we're in a financial position right now
that we would be able to bear the cost
of
such
evaluation um on the court I think it
just it would have to be the parties
paying for it thank
you representative
Nelson thank you Madame Vice chair uh
that question was asked and I appreciate
it it was asked very nicely by
representative
Sher thank you representative Nelson
representative rice did you remember
thank you madam chair it came back to me
yay
so as someone who
has had some therapy and all of that I
know it's not readily available to get
in right away we do have a shortage are
you sure that because this is ordering
that it be done within 14 days of the
initial um petition for divorce and what
would happen if that can't be done in 14
days because that's like two weeks like
I can't get in to see my therapist that
click thank you for the question
representative race so this is requiring
that it's ordered within 14 days of the
petition but it's not actually requiring
that the assessment take place until on
page two lines three and four that it
shall be within a reasonable period of
time not to exceed 8 weeks after the
order okay thank
you any further
questions thank you representative thank
you next I'll call Betty
gay you've asked for four minutes
thank you very much for allowing me to
talk about something that is dear to my
heart all the questions that you're
asking are really good what you don't
realize is those questions could be used
for what is going on right now there are
several this is this again is to adjust
uh address a really bad thing that's
happening in some family
courts and that is that the judge is
ordering and I use we we need to talk
about Judges sometimes because that term
is not correct for most Family Court
judges it's a different term and it's a
different legal they're supposed to do
that job but that's also a whole subject
that the family court is different on
um the same questions you're asking need
to be applied to what happens usually in
family court and that is that counseling
is ordered and they don't have to pay
for it the court doesn't they don't
order it from in my experience they
don't order it for people who are
Indigent they order it for people they
think can pay and it's really crass at
its worst um I knew somebody who was
ordered to pay ordered to more
counseling for both her kids and for her
not for the other parent who was the
abuser more than her her cost out of
pocket would be more than she made
cleared per week it didn't bother the
judge because he knew her parents had
money and they actually told her your
parents can they can pay for this now
that's got to be illegal but it was done
for years so this this bill says before
you order counseling and all your
questions about who's going to pay for
it and how does it order it and how long
is it going to last all of those
questions should be applied to what what
is happening right now because
counseling gets ordered all the time and
of course the court doesn't pay for
it let's say why not if the first
counseling you're going to order is
evaluate the people there and see if
they need counseling and if so what kind
so this is just saying if you think
counseling sounds like a good idea first
have the people evaluated don't just
start ordering
counseling for months at a time it was
tragic one minute so um I'm I hope I've
said this if you can make me clarify
what I'm saying if you're going to order
counseling let's first do an evaluation
to see what kind should be ordered and
maybe even if it should be ordered I
think counseling is very useful I'm not
against it I've certainly gone to my
share over my decades so I'm not
negative at all about counseling but
let's figure out because the judge
usually isn't a counselor who can figure
out you know the best assessment himself
30 seconds thank
you any
questions I give my oh representative
sidel thank you madam Vice chair I just
just so are you in support of this bill
or opposition oh I'm very very much in
support of this Bill thank
you thank you honorable gay I appreciate
your time and and your testimony thank
you any more
questions thank you next I'll call Mr
John
dejoy Mr de you didn't specify any
particular amount of time so I take it
you're going to be as brief as you
usually are thank you madam chair I will
be as as concise but robust in my
testimony as I'm able to I would expect
no less sir thank you madam chair
members of the committee it's a pleasure
to be be before children and family law
for the record I am here
representing the National Association of
Social Workers as well as the New
Hampshire Psychological
Association both of my clients are
strongly opposed to this legislation
this legislation is well-
intended but it is actually a solution
in search of a
problem I was contacted by the prime
sponsor and a constituent of hers last
uh week before last and they asked to
meet with me which I did with my client
um from the social workers we had about
an hourlong meeting and talked about
this legislation talked about the
amendment before you I won't discuss
it and talked about what their concerns
truly
were this bill we initially began
opposing this because it mandates an
evaluation we are always opposed to
courts mandating an evaluation just
offand there needs to be a reason for an
evaluation the court can determine that
but there needs to be a reason the bill
and the amendment do not provide that
necessity through the conversation
though
the constituent of the Prime
sponsor mentioned several times that her
concern was that judges can order these
now but they just aren't judges aren't
ordering evaluations and she said we
want to this bill is to make sure judges
always order
evaluations as we talked more and more
it became clear to us that this is not
about kids being evaluated it's not
about evaluations at all this is a
process issue in court that the
constituent does not like the way the
proceedings are going and I don't know
whether her concerns have Merit or not
they might but I do know that by traum
retraumatization that that's not going
to get her to where she wants to be I
actually said to her even if this bill
passes you will still be disappointed in
in six months because what you want to
happen is not going to happen we
encouraged her to talk to the
administrator head of the family court I
also spoke with the prime sponsor and
and walked her through some of the
pieces of a performance audit that this
really ought to be with chair Parson and
the task force he's working on regarding
the family court or perhaps a
performance audit of the family court to
understand what truly is within their
jurisdiction as judges and what's
happening within the court system that
might be amendable to some kind of
administrative or legislative
change this bill isn't
that thank you very much any questions
for M Mr
dejoy representative Raymond thank you
uh Madam chairwoman um and thank you for
taking my question so what um is the
breadth of what judges can order now as
the law currently stands in cases of a
divorce or a parenting plan that you
know is a little bit tense
representative I thank you very much for
your question unfortunately I'm not a
judge nor a lawyer nor do I play one on
TV I would turn to the gentleman to your
left who is a lawyer and might be able
to provide additional detail that I
would not have any way of
knowing followup thank you madam
chairman uh so maybe more in your
Wheelhouse in the bill under section two
it lists all of the things that would
happen in a risk assessment um is is
this stuff that a psychologist would be
able to answer or do in a one-time
meeting with a
child so this is this is the other
reason why we we were opposing the bill
it's it's not what they're going to look
at so a risk assessment typically what a
risk assessment means both for social
workers and psychologists and other
mental health professionals a risk
assessment means is the person at RIS
risk risk typically is determined by
suicidal ideation and intent or
homicidal ideation and intent that is
typically what is
risk you can as a mental health
professional do a risk
assessment of whether a child is a risk
of running away from a program of
whether a child is at risk of some other
feature but a risk assessment in of
itself does
not um does not look at shared or
induced pers
delusions which quite honestly there is
not a scale that I'm familiar with that
um assesses for prescor delusion that is
learned over time through therapy not
typically except an extreme Cas is not
typically from an
evaluation
um what this really sounds like is
another way to go at re um you had a
bill last year on
um
family thank you representative if you
shared
it there there is a one of the courts or
two of the courts in the state last last
couple of years have
been requiring evaluations to try to
reconnect the family through um through
treatment reunification thank you so we
oppose reunification because it's not a
treatment it is not a treatment by any
recognized um body of practitioners what
it is is it's a way to coerce a child
and or a spouse into reconnecting this
the way these um read representative
Raymond is similar to what the intent of
reunification therapy was thank you that
was my Amendment last year we wrote that
bill so I appreciate it thank you thank
you madam chair for your
Indulgence you're welcome any further
questions representative
love thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um I've got more than a few
constituents male and female who have uh
said that the the children use the word
coerced and that's the one I want to put
on they're being coerced into hating
staying away from people uh we had a
woman testify earlier on a grandparents
Bill how her grandchildren are being
coerced to not even look at her when
they're playing sports um wouldn't this
bring out a a coercion of children and
how how low can you go using using
children to uh you know and and I boy I
I think the court needs to address it
and this this would just put a put a put
an emphasis on hey Court you you're
you're missing out on this you know it's
already it might already be in in in
statute but you're ignoring it and um
you know it's just a reminder that that
they should
be representative I I think let me try
to pull out the question that I that I
heard to to respond to you um and as I
said my clients are not experts in the
court system they're not indicating that
there's no issues with court process
they're indicating that this approach to
address with to address a court process
issue was not the way to address it
would an evaluation detect
coercion I suppose an extreme cases it
could but it's equally likely that the
ceran wouldn't be present or the child
wouldn't even talk to the
therapist you know there's a lot going
on in Family
Court there are unfortunately winners
and losers through the family court
process and many many times folks who
are not on the prevailing side feel as
though they didn't get a fair shake and
they may not have but they just as
likely may have forcing a kid through
evaluations of this sort don't address
that doesn't change
that I've been before this committee
many many times over the last decade and
typically I am testifying in support of
keeping families together when whenever
it's
possible I think that is the
best benefit for the child the best
interest I think representative Raymond
asked before the best interest of the
child is typically to have two loving
parents we can't legislate
that that's the truly unfortunate part
we can't legislate parents to be loving
parents I'd like to think that every
parent is a loving parent and cares for
their kids I really do and that's where
I start from but I've I've seen stories
in this
committee that call that into
question thank you very much for that uh
represent you all set you all set
representative love thank you
representative share uh speaking only as
the gentleman to the left
of um I'm looking at uh for RSA 461 d a
colon 4 and as I read it it it asks the
court to develop a um a parenting
plan um uh Roman numeral one asked the
court to develop a parenting plan
um is it fair to say that even without
this legislation the court can say to
the parties hey you know now it would be
helpful for me if uh we if we could have
uh the child or children at issue uh
talk to uh an individual um a a clinical
psychologist or a therapist of some sort
does as far as you understand it that's
not prohibited currently is it my
understanding that could happen today
okay thank you
thank you again uh any further
questions thank you Mr toy next I'll
call Mary
Krueger Mary you've asked for five
minutes yes thank you um and thank you
madam chairman and U members of the
committee my name is Mary Krueger and
for the record I am an attorney with New
Hampshire legal assistance we are a
Statewide civil legal nonprofit
providing services to people in poverty
um one of the projects that we operate
is the domestic violence
um advocacy project of which I'm the
supervising attorney um last year we
completed uh about just about 240 cases
which would include protection order
cases es divorce cases and parenting
cases our victims that we represent um
suffer High lethality violence um so
these are the most risky cases um that
go through our court system I'm here to
oppose HB 335 FN on behalf of New
Hampshire legal assistant and we are
doing this um mainly because there's a
few reasons but one there's a strong
policy in our state to consider the
children's best interest in these cases
and to really do no harm um this um Bill
if uh enacted would harm children
exposing them to um very
invasive um
and uh evaluations where they're really
thrust into the middle of a contested
parenting case and that Al loan is
damaging to Children I've testified
before about how our courts really
encourage parents to try to reach
agreements and try to think of the best
interest of their children so we're
talking about the cases where that's not
happening um right now the courts can
appoint Guardians at lium um and their
job is to investigate issues that the
court has or the parties have raised um
at issue in a contested divorce and
parenting case and um that system does
have its issues and I've been in front
of this committee over the last probably
10 years talking about that however that
is a system that exists where a guardian
ad lium could do an independent
investigation for the court when there's
allegations that one parent is um trying
to turn the other the children against
the other parent which I think this is
what is uh being addressed here in this
bill as I read it um and I wanted to
point out for this committee that
there's a case called in reberg and I
put it in the footnote to uh the written
testimony here for an important reason
and it talks about the right of privacy
of children in these contested cases
where neither parent is permitted in a
contested custody case to invoke or
um um like wave a privilege for a child
from their therapeutic session and that
way the therapy uh session is considered
a confidential space for a child to be
able to process everything without being
discovered by either parent as to what
they're disclosing and that's important
to the therapeutic process and that case
really talks about how that outweighs a
parent's fundamental right to parent a
child in these cases and I think it's
really important because this implicates
that privacy issue for children and
could be really harmful to them if it's
enacted and there's other ways for
courts to get out this information
already so we're asking that this
committee uh vote itl on this Bill thank
you thank you any
questions representative rice thank you
madam chair thank you um could I didn't
get a copy of the written testimony can
you email it to me so I can see that
link yeah I did make um 16 copies so
representative sure maybe snagged one
never mind thank you thanks so much um
and I'm also happy to circulate the enry
Berg I didn't make copies of that um I
have one here would would the um
committee like that okay it's a really
good case I think for a lot of the
issues that you're handling here would
you be so kind as to turn that in for
the um um file so if anybody wants to
refer to it they can yes thank you
kindly representative
Sher thank you madam chair um in in the
interest of transparency I uh uh the the
uh person testifying had The Misfortune
of Being a former student of mine so
um thinking about the the guardian at
lium the guardian at lium job is to to
connect with the child uh if it's
appointed for the guardian ad item and
uh develop ideally a relationship with a
child is that a fair way to put
it they wouldn't necessarily develop a
relationship with the child in my
experience um they might meet with the
child once or twice depending on how
long the case is going
along
so but they they can talk to a child's
therapist and that's one way to protect
that confidential information and they
can get orders to ensure that that be
kept confidential but they can utilize
that information from a therapist to um
inform how to make recommendations to
the court about what's going on thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you chair recognizes Gail
drowart asked to speak for three minutes
let's see how you do
sorry for the record Gail drob at
Amhurst New
Hampshire I'm in support of HB 335 and I
appreciate Mr J de Joy's um test
testimony I did meet with him um and
this bill came to light because of his
previous testimony on reunification
therapy that a risk assessment if
anything should be ordered by these
judges they should be ordering nothing
more than a risk assessment so that's
how this bill came to light
um testimony before this committee over
and over children being withheld from a
parent whether in a contentious custody
case or allegations of Abus or neglect
to DCF
the interference with custody could be
for weeks months sometimes years HB 1162
in 2020 outlined psychological Mal
treatment and prior to January 1st of
2021 the Department of Health and Human
Services divis Division of
families in partnership with the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence shall provide training
to DCF child protection staff courta
appointed special Advocates Family Court
judges and other other system Partners
regarding the implementation of section
51 through 54 of that act interfering
with the child parent contact should be
a last measure and when the court has a
compelling State interest to do so
forcing children to mourn the loss of a
living parent and forcing a parent to
mourn the loss of a living child has
lifelong consequences for
both as well as extended family for
these reasons please support the
passages of this bill the mental
emotional state of New Hampshire
children and protect these children from
a childhood filled with
trauma all allow them to have a
childhood they do not have to recover
from any
questions no no and there is a risk
assessment from a clinical psychologist
protocols for a risk assessment um
consider that in your thanks
chair recognizes Dana
Al you're even more Brave you asked for
one to two minutes thank you Mr chair
can we go up to three given the amount
of comments I've
heard uh Dana alra nashille New
Hampshire uh I heard it said earlier
that this bill is a uh solution in
search of a problem I submit I'm the
problem that this bill is a solution for
I've heard it earlier said that uh we
have winners and losers in family court
because it's an adversarial
process I respectfully suggest the
committee question that why must there
be winners and losers why can't there be
winners and
winners I've heard concerns raised about
what does this
cost I suggest at least in my own case
it would have cost far less than over
$110,000 in gal fees with the GL is a
lawyer and the best friend of the
judge would cost less than six figures
of lawyer fees in an adversarial
proceeding why are we subjecting
children to adversarial proceedings
if there might be
Alternatives why can't people trained in
therapeutic
modalities have a crack at solving some
of these family conflicts in divorce
cases sort of before
we escalate the conflict up to you know
let's just go at it with a lawyer for
Mom a lawyer for pado and another lawyer
for the kid none of whom are trained in
therapeutic
modalities uh many other states like
California at least for the G Pace
assign that uh sort of evaluation to
someone trained in therapy not
law and uh so I would just submit to you
I support this very very
much uh as fond as I am of sh uh I think
May is fine
uh but I would very much like to see
this past and it would have gone a whole
way to reducing all of the burdens on
the judicial system that cost so much
money so much pain and so much trauma
over seven years of protracted
litigation with that said I'll take
questions if there are any any questions
for Mr
alre seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you welcome back thank
you chair recognizes Sarah
tfon
hello my name is Sarah tson and I come
before you today as a protective and
caring parent from gtown to speak in
opposition to House Bill
335 as someone deeply invested in the
wellbe being of children in our state I
feel compelled to raise several serious
concerns about this
legislation first I must address the
concerning lack of transparency
surrounding this bill I attempted to
contact the primary sponsor of the bill
twice to learn more like what
individuals or organizations brought
this to their attention and have not yet
received a response this committee and
the public deserve to know whose
interests are truly being served by this
legislation the Practical implementation
of this bill presents significant
problems it directly conflicts with the
law passed in 2024 prohibiting
reunification therapy and appears to be
merely a repackaged counter Bill the
provisions regarding reun reunification
therapy and the requirement for therapy
to be recommended by both parties and
accepted by Insurance are in direct
conflict with HP
335 of particular concern is the
requirement for core ordered
psychological evaluations and risk
assessments these evaluations which
typically cost thousands of dollars are
not covered by Insurance furthermore
finding qualified providers who can
complete these evaluations within the
Bill's 14-day requirement is virtually
impossible in our state this creates an
unreasonable financial burden
particularly impacting domestic violence
survivors who may already be struggling
with limited resources and it is not
uncommon for coercive control
perpetrators to intentionally Force
former partners into financial debt or
impoverish using the family court system
we must also consider the traumatic
impact of mandatory psychological
evaluations especially on children as a
caring and protective parent I canot
emphasize enough how forcing children to
undergo such evaluations can cause
lasting psychological harm we do not
want to be an institution contributing
to adverse childhood
experiences I challenge this committee
to investigate who stands to financially
benefit from this legislation more
importantly I urge you to find even one
documented case where forced therapy
successfully restored a resistant parent
child relationship love and connection
is organic and willing therapy as well
by its very nature cannot be forced when
we attempt to do so we strip it of its
healing potential and transform it into
a punishment the very opposite of its
intended purpose therapy is a powerful
tool of resiliency and we do not want to
remove that tool from the tool blocks of
parents and children who may come to
need it now or in their future by making
therapy a painful coercive and negative
experience at its core this bill appears
to be built around the concept of
Parental alienation syndrome a debunked
theory that has become the only mental
illness apologies to the man on the left
diagnosed by attorneys rather than
mental health
professionals parental alienation
syndrome is frequently used as a counter
claim in Family Court when abuse
allegations arise potentially putting
Children at Risk there is a reason why
you are not seeing the words
reunification therapy or parental
alienation syndrome in this bill
although the alternative words used in
it are just a guise our state just
prohibited this very act HB 335
proposes children are human beings with
valid feelings and experiences they like
adults naturally withdraw from
situations where they feel feel unsafe
or neglected it is not a syndrome
requiring forced Intervention when a
child resists contact with someone who
has cause them harm it is a natural
protective response let's keep our
attention where it best serves the
safety and well-being of children
identifying and preventing abuse and
neglect as legislators parents and
community members we have a fundamental
responsibility to protect New
Hampshire's children this bail Bill
fails to serve their best interests
lacks transparency and will cause more
harm than good thank you will you take
questions yes questions for the witness
anyone seeing none thank you for your
testimony I have no more pink cards on
335 and I don't see anybody making a Mad
Dash for
them so with that I will close the
hearing on House Bill 335
five and a couple of things for the
committee please um number one we are
getting growing pressure from the
speaker's office they say that we have a
habit of sending them bills that go on a
consent
well all committees should be like us
then I say but I know what they mean and
so two weeks from today we're going to
exact every bill that was heard two
weeks ago last week and
today that have not yet been exec we'll
do that on that Tuesday morning two
weeks from today so if you want to work
on them if you have amendments if if if
um get it
done we'd like to see the Amendments
ahead of time if possible so we can come
ready to discuss so that's item number
one item number two the
um bill
hb10 which is Parental Bill of
Rights uh I just testified before a
committee and I said if you've read my
bill ignore
it here's the amendment which is a
replace all and sometimes that happens
we weren't ready new evidence comes to
light there was a deadline what have you
the um amendment to hb10 that I'm
passing around uh if you could take as
many as needed that way and I'll pass
the wrist this way this is the amendment
to
hb10 the parental Bill of Rights I'm
giving you two weeks notice on it
because two weeks from today in the
afternoon this is what we will be
looking at so this will give you that
advaned notice uh perhaps we could let
the two members who are not here today
to know to access this um
do we have enough
copies I have another copy here coming
around
representative in fact I have everybody
have
one everybody we might want to leave two
with the clerk for the two members who
are not here uh so they can
re I'll let you guys worries figure that
out okay what am I bid
I give you
$5 F
298 what 298 I'm not giving you a
disc okay here's another
one okay I'll leave it here all right
I'll leave it here all right any
questions on that we're going to look at
this I doubt we'll execute two weeks
from today but we are definitely going
to have a hearing probably a good bit of
that afternoon every other bill that
we've looked at that has not yet been
exact uh if you want to write amendments
fine if you want to do other things
that's fine the subcommittee I appointed
this morning representative Greg will be
in touch with you as to when your first
meeting will be and if it's soon uh get
that information to Special K so it can
go into the calendar please okay anybody
else committee uh we wish to thank our
visitors today um feel free to come back
both of you including the lawyer any
time that lawyer you're already here
excuse me I believe it's the gentleman
on the left from now
on uh we do recognize you as the
gentleman on the
left this concludes our uh hearings
today yeah oh